I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hey! Are you ready for a welcome party that no one asked for and no one wants to throw?
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好！嘿！你准备好迎接一场没人要求、也没人想办的欢迎派对了吗？
Well, I am. I'm also ready to haul some cube. Yeah, let's haul cube today. It's season 8 episode 20. This was written by Steve Healy and directed by Ed Helms. Here's your summary. After being instructed by Robert California to throw Nellie a welcome party, the group decides to prank her by making it intentionally awful.
嗯，我准备好了。我也准备好大干一场了。没错，今天让我们大干一场吧。这是第八季第二十分集。本集由史蒂夫·希利编剧，埃德·赫尔姆斯导演。以下是剧情梗概：在罗伯特·加利福尼亚的指示下，大家要为内莉举办一场欢迎派对，于是众人决定故意把派对办得糟糕透顶，以此来恶搞她。
Dwight and Jim reluctantly help Nellie move into her new apartment and they get a glimpse into her heartbreak. Meanwhile, Andy and Aaron have an important pit stop to make on their road trip back to Scranton. Andy is going to finally break up with Jessica. With Aaron, present. I know what to say. I have to say. We have texted about it.
德怀特和吉姆不情愿地帮内莉搬进她的新公寓，并得以一窥她心碎的过往。与此同时，安迪和艾琳在开车返回斯克兰顿的公路旅行中有一个重要的中途停留点。安迪终于要和杰西卡分手了。当着艾琳的面。我知道该说些什么。我必须说。我们已经为此发过短信了。
We have feelings about it. We have strong feelings about it. Fast fact number one, guest star Brett Gellman as the magician. I need to just clap for a second. I need to clap for a second. I need to clap for a second. I love him. He was so fantastic.
我们对此有感觉。我们对此有强烈的感受。第一条快讯，客串明星布雷特·加尔曼饰演魔术师。我需要鼓掌一秒钟。我需要鼓掌一秒钟。我需要鼓掌一秒钟。我爱死他了。他太棒了。
We're going to talk a lot about it, but oh my gosh, did this guy make us laugh? I did not know Brett Gellman before he guest started on the office. He came in and we didn't know what to do with him. He was so funny. He destroyed us all. He did.
我们接下来会大聊特聊，但天哪，这家伙把我们逗得太开心了吧？在布雷特·加尔曼客串《办公室》之前，我并不认识他。他来了之后，我们都不知道该拿他怎么办。他太搞笑了。他把我们所有人都征服了。确实如此。
You guys out there probably recognize him from the gazillion things he's been in. He gets a lot of love for stranger things. I absolutely loved him in Fleabag and Love. Everything he did in Fleabag was perfection. I do have a crossover shout out. Oh, yes. Yes. Not Monk, but fresh off the boat. He played Dusty Nuggett, and I played Amy Chestnut.
你们大家可能在无数他参演过的作品中认出过他。他因出演《怪奇物语》而备受喜爱。我绝对爱惨了他在《伦敦生活》和《爱情》中的表现。他在《伦敦生活》里的一切堪称完美。我确实有一个联动致意。哦，是的。是的。不是《神探阿蒙》，而是《菜鸟新移民》。他饰演达斯蒂·纳杰特，而我饰演艾米·切斯纳特。
So, did you guys work together? We did not. Oh, but we have a crossover moment, crossover connection. Well, before he was on the office, he had done a lot of shorts for funnier dye presents. This ran on HBO. Very short-lived. He had been on Kirby Arnthusiasm.
所以，你们两个合作过吗？我们没有。哦，不过我们有一个联动时刻、联动纽带。嗯，在他出演《办公室》之前，他曾为《搞笑搞死人》制作过许多短片。这个节目在HBO播出。生命非常短暂。他曾出演过《抑制热情》。
He had been on board to death. And it was our writer, Hallstead Sullivan, who pitched Brett for the role. He didn't know him personally, but he was a fan of his work. And one of the Funny or Die episodes he had recently done was a 16- one man musical called 1000 cats. It is really, really funny.
他曾出演过《无聊至死》。正是我们的编剧霍尔斯特德·沙利文向剧组推荐了布雷特这个角色。他不认识布雷特本人，但他一直是布雷特作品的粉丝。他最近参与的其中一集《搞笑搞死人》是一个16人的独角音乐剧，名叫《1000只猫》。这真的、真的很搞笑。
I watched it. Brett dresses as a black cat. He has a headband on with little black ears. It's very serious. Very serious. Brett did an interview where he said he had been doing it as a 30-minute live show at upright Citizensburgade for like eight years, and then it ended up on the Funnier Di HBO show.
我看了。布雷特打扮成一只黑猫。他戴着一个带有黑色小猫耳的发带。非常严肃。非常严肃。布雷特在一次采访中说，他在“アップライト・シチズンズ・ブリゲード”（Upright Citizens Brigade）把这个节目当作30分钟的现场秀演了大约八年，然后它最终登上了《搞笑搞死人》的HBO节目。
The Funnier Di sketch opened with a video of his character talking about his stage show 1000 Cats and why it's important to the world. Oh my gosh, I think we should listen to it. Okay. One thousand cats is not a play. It's not a musical. It's not even really a performance. It is a universal consciousness that is physicalized
《搞笑搞死人》的素描开场是一个视频，他的角色在视频中谈论他的舞台秀《1000只猫》以及它对世界的重要性。哦天哪，我觉得我们应该听听看。好的。《1000只猫》不是一出戏剧。它不是音乐剧。它甚至算不上真正的表演。它是一种通过我具象化的普世意识。
through me. Of course, the appropriate venue is not the theater that I will be performing it in. Really, there's only one venue that would do 1,000 cats justice, and that venue is the Vatican. I am performing 1,000 cats yet. I am not performing 1,000 cats, because 1,000 cats doesn't even exist while at the same time.
当然，最合适的场地不是我将要表演它的那个剧院。说实话，能让《1000只猫》实至名归的场地只有一个，那个场地就是梵蒂冈。我正在表演《1000只猫》然而。我并没有在表演《1000只猫》，因为《1000只猫》甚至不存在，与此同时。
1000 cats is the only thing that exists. So then it cuts to the performance. I saw a part of the performance. It's amazing. It's 1,000 cats, but they have 9,000 lives and 9,000 stories and he's going to tell each one. Each one. And sing. Sing them. Yes. It's a musical. It's a musical. Did we mention it's a one-man musical about 1,000 cats? So Hallstead was familiar, and when they were breaking down the script, he said, I know who should play the magician. Allison Jones put him on tape.
《1000只猫》是唯一存在的东西。然后镜头切到了表演现场。我看了表演的一部分。太神奇了。里面有1000只猫，但它们有9000条命和9000个故事，他要讲完每一个。每一个。还要唱歌。把它们唱出来。是的。这是一部音乐剧。这是一部音乐剧。我们提到过这是一部关于1000只猫的独角音乐剧吗？所以霍尔斯特德很熟悉他，当他们在拆解剧本时，他说我知道谁该演魔术师。艾莉森·琼斯把他的试镜录像交了上去。
Everybody watched this tape and loved him. And, you know, Ed Helms was the director of this when they gave Ed the tape. He was so excited because he had known Brett for years, you know, from their days of both doing upright citizens brigade. And he was like, yes, yes, he's the guy. I can't imagine anyone else playing this part.
每个人看了这段录像都非常喜欢他。而且，你知道，当剧组把录像交给埃德·赫尔姆斯时，他作为本集的导演兴奋极了。因为他认识布雷特好几年了，你知道的，从他们俩都在“即兴公民旅团”演出的日子开始。他就觉得，对，对，就是他。我无法想象还有谁能演这个角色。
And I'm sad we don't see more of him. I'm like, why couldn't someone have dated him on the show? Right? Right? Who would it have been? Angela? No, I don't think she would like anything to do with magic. She would date the 1 cats guy though maybe.
我很遗憾我们在剧中没看到他更多戏份。我在想，为什么剧中没有人跟他约会呢？对吧？对吧？会是谁呢？安吉拉？不，我觉得她才不想跟任何魔法扯上关系呢。不过她或许会跟那个《1000只猫》的家伙约会吧。
Would you be a true man who has a musical about 1000 cats? A hundred percent. I think so. All right, well, let's move on to fast fact number two. We had a very special cameo on this show that caused a fan mail flurry. We got so much mail about it. That cameo is the shoebox that Dwight and Jim find in Nellie's apartment. You know, Benjamin that holds all the photos of Henry. Yeah, it's her sad box. Yes. Let me explain why this caused a fan mail flurry. All of our letters
你会和一个有一部关于1000只猫的音乐剧的真正的男人约会吗？百分之百。我想我会的。好吧，那我们进入第二条快讯。我们在本期节目中有一个非常特别的客串，引发了一阵粉丝来信狂潮。我们收到了大量关于这事的信件。那个客串就是德怀特和吉姆在内莉公寓里找到的那个鞋盒。你知道的，那个装着亨利所有照片的叫本杰明的盒子。对，就是她的伤心盒。是的。让我解释一下为什么这会引发粉丝来信狂潮。我们所有的信件
were from folks in the UK. First off, Becky O. from County Durham, England said, I noticed the shoe box is for the brand Clark's shoes. This is pure perfection. Clark's is such a well-known British shoe brand. I remember before a new school term, my mom would take me to Clark's and it would be so, so busy. You would have to get a ticket and have to wait till they called your ticket number for a foot measure and then choose your school shoes Any box could have been used for this But the commitment and attention to detail to use an iconic British high street brand was just perfection I am obsessed with this detail was this a fill shade decision. I cannot express how amazing
都来自英国的朋友。首先，来自英格兰达勒姆郡的贝姬·O说，我注意到那个鞋盒是Clarks（其乐）鞋品牌的。这简直完美。Clarks是一个非常知名的英国鞋履品牌。我记得在新学期开始之前，我妈妈会带我去Clarks买鞋，店里总是人山人海。你得拿个号码牌，等着他们叫到你的号去量脚丫，然后再挑选你的校鞋。随便什么盒子都可以拿来用，但为了道具精益求精，竟然选用了一个标志性的英国高街品牌，这简直太完美了。我对这个细节着迷不已，这难道是菲尔·谢伊（美术指导）的决定吗？我简直无法表达我觉得
I think this kind of detail is that That is fantastic. I totally missed that. I missed it too. Oh my gosh, thank you for writing in about it. Annabee from Lancashire United Kingdom said, I need to know everything about the amazing shoebox choice in this episode. This is exactly where someone like Nelly would have bought her workshoes from. And Liam C. and Glasgow Scotland said, I love that Nellyie's box of photos
这种细节有多棒。这太棒了。我完全没注意到。我也没注意到。哦天哪，谢谢你们写信来谈论这件事。来自英国兰开夏郡的安娜比说，我想知道关于这一集里那个惊艳的鞋盒选择的一切。这绝对是像内莉这样的人会买工作鞋的地方。还有来自苏格兰格拉斯哥的利亚姆·C说，我喜欢内莉的照片盒，
aka Benjamin was in a Clark shoe box. I have fond memories of my mom taking me to get my feet measured at the end of the summer before starting a new school year as always props to the prop department. So great. Well everyone, I checked the script and there was no mention of the kind of shoebox. This was 100% fill-shay, paying attention to detail. I love that it resonated with so many people. This is just a sample of the letters we got. And I love that the memories that brought back were people doing there before school shopping,
也就是本杰明，居然装在一个Clarks的鞋盒里。我有一段美好的回忆，那就是在每个新学年开始前的夏天结束时，我妈妈带我去量脚丫买鞋。向道具部门致以一如既往的敬意。太棒了。好了各位，我查阅了剧本，上面根本没有提到鞋盒的种类。这是百分之百由菲尔·谢伊完成的，他对细节的关注太到位了。我很高兴它能引起这么多人的共鸣。这只是我们收到的信件中的冰山一角。我喜欢它唤起的那些回忆，那是人们在上学前去购物、
foot measure and shoe shopping. Yeah, I remember doing that going, there was one children shoe shoe store in the mall and you would go and get your foot measured and pick out a pair of sneakers or whatever. This is such a sweet memory and I love that Phil got it. He nailed it. Nailed it.
量脚丫和买鞋的场景。对，我记得我也去过，商场里有一家童鞋店，你去那儿量脚丫，然后挑选一双运动鞋什么的。这是一段多么甜蜜的回忆，我很高兴菲尔注意到了这一点。他做到了极致。太完美了。
Well, I thought it might be fun to do a small deep dive on Clarks, this company that delighted people so much. Great. So here we go. Clarks is a company that delighted people so much. Great. So here we go. Clarks is a British international shoe manufacturer and retailer. It was founded in 1825 by Cyrus Clark
好吧，我觉得深入了解一下Clarks这个让大家如此开心的公司可能会很有趣。太好了。那我们开始吧。Clarks是一家英国国际鞋类制造商和零售商。它于1825年由赛勒斯·克拉克
in the small village of Sweet Somerset, England. This is the most adorable small town. I looked at the picture. Of course. Of course. Yes. Of course. I want to go. I already course. I want to go.
在英格兰萨默塞特郡的小村庄斯特里特创立。这是一个极其可爱的小镇。我看了照片。当然。当然。没错。当然。我想去。我已经...当然。我想去。
I already know. I want to go. I know I do too. This town only has about 11,000 people living there, but the Clarks World Headquarters is still there. Love that. The company has about 1,400 branded stores and franchises around the world. You know there's one in our mall, but I wonder if it's the same company.
我早就知道了。我想去。我知道我也想去。这个小镇只有大约11000名居民，但Clarks的全球总部仍然在那里。太棒了。该公司在全球拥有大约1400家品牌专卖店和特许经营店。你知道我们的商场里就有一家，但我不知道它是不是同一家公司。
It has to be right. Now I'm excited to go there even more. The company is very well-known for their desert boot and their wallaby. The wallaby is what Walter White wore on Breaking Bad. And of course, children's school shoes. I am pretty sure that I wore clerks on the office. I think they do really comfy work shoes for the lady executive. You know, it's like a heel, but it's like a chunky heel, a chunky low heel with good arch support. I mean, we all know I wore sass.
肯定是的，对吧？现在我更想去那里了。该公司以其沙漠靴和袋鼠鞋而闻名。袋鼠鞋就是沃尔特·怀特在《绝命毒师》里穿的那款。当然，还有儿童校鞋。我很确信我在《办公室》里穿过Clarks。我觉得他们为女高管制作了非常舒适的工作鞋。你知道的，就像是高跟鞋，但它是那种粗跟，一种带有良好足弓支撑的厚底低跟鞋。我的意思是，大家都知道我穿的是Sass。
And then the working man, they've got some nice loafers. I've been all over the website, clearly. But here's what I needed to know. Is there a Clark's factory that we can tour? Is it in England and that cute little town? No, that's where the headquarters are. No, there is no factory tour. I did find the Clark's shoe museum, but unfortunately, it closed in 2019 after 70 years. It just closed. I found a blog called Travel with Kevin and Ruth. Okay. There are Canadian couple who are in their early 60s. They've been married for 39 years and they blogged all about visiting the Clarks Shoomuseum. They have great photos.
然后对于上班族男士，他们有一些不错的乐福鞋。很显然，我把他们的网站浏览了个遍。但这是我需要知道的：有没有我们可以参观的Clarks工厂？它在英格兰那个可爱的小镇吗？不，那是总部所在地。不，没有工厂参观。我找到了Clarks鞋履博物馆，但不幸的是，它在运营了70年后于2019年闭馆了。它刚刚关闭。我找到了一个叫《与凯文和露丝一起旅行》的博客。好吧。他们是一对六十出头的加拿大夫妇。他们结婚39年了，他们把参观Clarks鞋履博物馆的经历写成了博客。他们拍了很棒的照片。
But unfortunately, that's as close as we're gonna get, Ange. Can I please put Kevin and Ruth's blog link in our stories? Cause I'm sure they would be delighted. I would love to check it out myself. They have a great blog, they have lots of pictures, and they just travel all around. Amazing. Yeah. Maybe we should meet up with them somewhere in Kevin and Ruth.
但不幸的是，安吉，这就是我们能接近它的极限了。我能把凯文和露丝的博客链接发到我们的快拍里吗？因为我确信他们会很高兴的。我自己也很想去看看。他们的博客很棒，有很多照片，他们一直在到处旅行。太神奇了。是的。也许我们应该在某个地方和凯文、露丝见个面。
Kevin and Ruth, we can be on our blog. All right, finally, fast back number three. Office ladies announcements. Yes. These announcements are based on some popular mailbag letters. Yes, they are. In our general mailbox. First off, Peyton from Georgia and many others sent in requests asking if we would please update
凯文和露丝，我们可以上你们的博客。好吧，最后是第三条快讯。办公室女士公告。是的。这些公告是根据一些受欢迎的听众来信做出的。是的，确实如此。在我们的常规收件箱里。首先，来自佐治亚州的佩顿和许多其他人发来请求，问我们是否能更新
the Office ladies Instagram story highlight. I did it, guys. I did it. I sat down one day and updated them all. I'm sorry, I got a little behind. Yes. We are very excited to announce that all past episode stories are now available. So when you're listening and you hear us say,
《办公室女士》的Instagram快拍精选。我做到了，伙计们。我做到了。有一天我坐下来把它们全部更新了。抱歉，我进度稍微有点落后了。是的。我们非常高兴地宣布，所有往期节目的快拍现在都可以观看啦。所以当你在收听节目并听到我们说，
we're gonna put it on the pod. You don't have to worry if you missed the day that we post it. Just go to the highlights. Go to the highlights. Next up, Angela, let's talk mugs. Okay, Suzanne in New York wants to know, where did they get Pam's pink mug on the show?
我们要把它发到播客里。你不必担心错过我们发布的那一天。直接去精选里找就行。去精选里找。接下来，安吉拉，我们来聊聊马克杯吧。好的，纽约的苏珊想知道，他们在剧中是从哪里弄到帕姆的粉红色马克杯的？
Suzanne wanted to know, Jenna was this mug originally yours? If so, where did you get it? Is there any brand on the bottom of the mug? I don't know where they got it, Suzanne. I looked, there's no logo anywhere on the mug. Everyone knows I still have it. It broke during season nine and they glued it back together for me. Perfectly. Yes. Perfectly. I can't drink coffee out of it because it will fall apart from the heat.
苏珊想知道，珍妮，这个马克杯原本是你的吗？如果是的话，你是在哪里买的？杯子底部有什么品牌标志吗？我不知道他们是从哪儿弄来的，苏珊。我找过了，马克杯上没有任何标志。大家都知道我还留着它。它在第九季的时候碎了，他们帮我把它粘好了。完美修复。是的。完美修复。我不能用它喝咖啡，因为热度会把它弄散架。
But now it's like a souvenir for you of your time on the office. And I love it. However, I did find a woman online who makes homemade pottery. She makes the Pam mug. I bought one from her. She didn't know it was me. I love it. I post about it all the time. It's made by Linda Renee pottery. I will link to her in our stories and you can find that in the now highlights. Jenna looked at me very pointedly and Angela, you will put it in. Will you highlight that? Yes, I will highlight Angela, you will put it in. Will you highlight that? Yes, I will highlight it. I will put it in stories.
但现在它对你来说就像是在《办公室》度过时光的一个纪念品。我爱死它了。不过，我在网上找到了一位制作手工陶器的女士。她制作帕姆的马克杯。我从她那儿买了一个。她当时不知道是我。我太喜欢了。我一直在网上发关于它的内容。它是琳达·雷内陶器制作的。我会在快拍里附上她的链接，你可以在最新的精选里找到它。珍妮意味深长地看着我，安吉拉，你会把它放进去的。你会把这个做成精选吗？是的，我会做成精选安吉拉，你会把它放进去的。你会把这个做成精选吗？是的，我会把它做成精选。我会把它发到快拍里。
Well, since we're on the subject of mugs, I want to plug if you have our office ladies merch mugs, Angela. They make great holiday gifts and I don't know if everybody out there is already thinking holidays, but I have a personal goal to get all of my holiday shopping done by December 15th. I want to be ahead this year, not kind. Okay. No end of the year scramble for gifts. No. Okay.
好吧，既然我们聊到了马克杯，我要宣传一下，如果你拥有我们的《办公室女士》周边马克杯，安吉拉。它们是很棒的节日礼物，我不知道外面的大家是不是已经在考虑节日了，但我给自己定了一个个人目标，要在12月15日之前买完所有的节日礼物。我今年想领先一步，而不是。好吧。年底不再手忙脚乱地买礼物。不。好吧。
So anyway, we have a really adorable, it is your mug, mug. It's blue. It's so cute. The writing is etched. It's not printed on its etched. And it's that sort of light blue, and then the rim of it has like a little kind of brown
所以无论如何，我们有一款非常可爱的“这就是你的马克杯”马克杯。它是蓝色的。太可爱了。上面的字是蚀刻上去的。不是印上去的，是蚀刻的。它是那种浅蓝色，然后杯子边缘有一点点像棕色那种
ceramic color. I want you guys to know we gave Steve Carell one of these when he came into studio. And he was like, this is a good mug. It is a good mug. Yeah, I love the shape. I love the size. I love it. I love holding it in my hand.
陶瓷的颜色。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫·卡瑞尔来到录音室时，我们送给了他一个。他说，这是一个好杯子。确实是个好杯子。是的，我喜欢它的形状。我喜欢它的尺寸。我爱不释手。我喜欢把它拿在手里的感觉。
Mm-hmm. That's what she said. She said all that. She did. It's $35. We also have our icons mug which has little office related images on it. There's a little teapot and a little yogurt lid metal and spilled chili. That one's so cute. I love it. It's $15. And since we are
嗯哼。她就是这么说的。她确实说了所有这些。她真的说了。售价35美元。我们还有我们的“偶像”马克杯，上面印着一些与办公室相关的小图案。有一个小茶壶、一个小酸奶盖和一个洒了的辣椒。那个太可爱了。我好喜欢。售价15美元。既然我们在
talking about the holidays early announcement, we are bringing back all of our ugly Christmas sweatshirts. They're really cozy including the party plan in committee one and we have other holiday stuff. We will post a link to all of our merch in our stories. Well done, lady. Thank you. And finally, Angela's journal. Lady, we got a lot of mail, a lot of requests. Melina from Idaho said, when is Angela gonna read from her journals again? It always makes me laugh out loud. Oh my gosh. So, Angie, I wrote you, I said, can you read from read from her journals again, it always makes me laugh out loud. Oh my gosh. So, Angie, I wrote you, I said, can you read
提前宣布节日消息，我们将重新推出我们所有的丑陋圣诞运动衫。它们真的非常舒适，包括派对策划委员会的那款，我们还有其他节日周边。我们会在快拍里发布所有周边商品的链接。干得漂亮，女士。谢谢。最后，安吉拉的日记。女士们，我们收到了大量的信件，大量的请求。来自爱达荷州的玛丽娜说，安吉拉什么时候会再次宣读她的日记？这总是让我哈哈大笑。哦天哪。所以，安吉，我给你写信了，我说，你能读一读从她的日记里读点东西吗，这总是让我哈哈大笑。哦天哪。所以，安吉，我给你写信了，我说，你能今天读一读
from your journal today? Yes, I can, I can. And guess what? I have some Angela journal updates for everyone. What are they? You know, we've been doing some home construction. And I haven't been able to get into our shed where we keep everything, right?
你的日记吗？是的，我可以，我可以。你们猜怎么着？我有一些安吉拉日记的最新进展要分享给大家。是什么？你知道的，我们一直在进行家居装修。我一直进不去我们存放所有东西的那个棚屋，对吧？
Finally got into the shed the other day. We're digging around all I was looking for was some seasonal doormats that I kept. I found a little box that said Angela's trailer. Jenna, I didn't even find this when we were writing our book. It had a blanket in it, a pillow. It had like some extra socks. Like who knows how long this little box has been in the way back of the shed,
前几天终于进了棚屋。我们在里面翻找，我原本只是在找我留着的一些季节性门垫。结果我发现了一个小盒子，上面写着“安吉拉的化妆车”。珍妮，我们在写书的时候甚至都没发现这个。里面有一条毯子，一个枕头。还有一些多余的袜子。天知道这个小盒子在棚屋最里面放了多久，
but it had a journal that I kept in my trailer and I wrote in it in the pilot season one and season two. Oh my gosh, Angela! I know. This is such a fine. It's such a fine. I wrote about the basketball episode, lady. You did not. Oh, All of these specific things. I was like in journal overload.
但里面有一本我在化妆车里写的日记，我在试播集、第一季和第二季时都在里面写过东西。哦天哪，安吉拉！我知道。这真是一个重大发现。真是个重大发现。女士，我甚至在里面写了关于篮球那一集的事。你才没有。哦。所有这些具体的事情。我当时感觉日记严重超载。
I was like, oh my god, what am I going to share all this? This is all. But I'm going to wait. I'm going to save those for special things. I wrote about filming the pilot. I have little notes that like Oscar gave me, taped inside the journal. I have my call sheet, lady.
我当时想，天哪，我该怎么把这些都分享出去？这全是。但我打算等一等。我要把这些留给特别的事情。我写了关于拍摄试播集的经历。我有奥斯卡给我的小纸条，粘在日记本里面。女士，我还有我的通告单。
Wow. I know. And we found so much stuff when we did our book. Is it making you want to call the publisher and say no need? No, no. We need to do a reprint. No. So I'm not going to read from that journal today.
哇。我知道。而且我们在写书的时候找到了那么多东西。这会让你想给出版商打电话说不用出了吗？不，不。我们需要重印一本。不。所以我今天不打算读那本日记。
I thought I would save that journal for when we get to the end of the run. That's fun. Yeah. Okay. Because I also found a card you gave me. Oh. I know. So I'm going to save all that.
我想把那本日记留到我们走到剧集终点时再读。那样才有趣。是的。好吧。因为我还找到了你送给我的一张卡片。哦。我知道。所以我要把所有这些都留到以后。
But today's Angela's journal, you guys, I have a journal that I titled Travel Journal. Oh, it's a travel journal. And I only wrote on it when I was on a plane or a bus or a train. And I guess guys, I really take inventory of who sits around me. You do, and when you travel, you leave me the most amazing messages about the people you were surrounded by. It's so entertaining
但今天的安吉拉日记，各位，我有一本我命名为《旅行日记》的日记本。哦，这是一本旅行日记。我只有在飞机上、大巴上或火车上时才会在上面写东西。我想各位，我真的会对坐在我周围的人进行一番盘点。你确实会，而且当你旅行时，你会给我留下关于你周围人群的最神奇的留言。太有趣了
and detailed. Okay, well here we go, you guys. This is written at 5.56 pm on a flight from Philadelphia to Los Angeles. It was 2005. Okay. Okay. I have now been on this flight for three hours. I write 556 p.m. in all caps, bored exclamation point. And then I write, Ken Quapas, the director of the office, actually has a movie on this plane. It's the sisterhood of the traveling pants. It was the feature movie. I saw it with Jenna at the theater when it came out. So I didn't feel like paying five dollars for headphones, frowny face. Oh yeah. Now they give you headphones. Yeah. This is in 2005. I go on to say, and now the odd couple is on. And I wish I had a pair of headphones. The guy behind me is pounding Jack Daniels and Coke. I think he's finally passed out.
而且细节满满。好吧，那我们开始吧，各位。这是在从费城飞往洛杉矶的航班上写的，时间是下午5点56分。那是2005年。好吧。好吧。我这趟航班已经坐了三个小时了。我用全大写字母写着“下午5点56分，无聊，感叹号”。然后我写道，执导《办公室》的肯·夸帕斯这架飞机上居然有一部他的电影。那是《牛仔裤的夏天》。它是主打电影。当年上映时我和珍妮一起在电影院看的。所以我才不想花五块钱买耳机，苦脸符号。哦对了。现在他们会给你发耳机。对。这是2005年。我接着写道，现在《鸳鸯谱》正在播。我真希望我有副耳机。我后面的家伙在猛灌杰克丹尼兑可乐。我觉得他终于昏过去了。
Oh, and the two ladies in front of me are feuding. One wanted the other to switch, so her husband could sit next to her, but the other lady said, no, she didn't want to give up her seat. It's been tense ever since. This is amazing. And this part cracks me up. The guy next to me has been diligently reading a book on Texas Holdham and furiously scribbling notes. He ran out of
哦，我前面的两位女士在吵架。一个想让另一个换座，好让她丈夫坐她旁边，但另一位女士说不，她不想让出自己的座位。从那以后气氛就一直很紧张。这太神奇了。这段把我笑死。我旁边的家伙一直在埋头苦读一本关于德州扑克的书，并且疯狂地在本子上狂记笔记。他记满了纸，
paper and has started to write on his plane ticket. He keeps covering his notes with his hand, like I'm gonna steal his secrets. I'd offer him a page out of this journal, but he's such a grump. I'd offer him a page out of this journal, but he's such a grump. We should be landing in half an hour, and I'm starving, and there's no snacks on US Airways, unless you want to pay $7 ridiculous. What happened to the airline industry?
开始在登机牌上写了。他一直用手挡着他的笔记，就好像我会偷他的秘密一样。我本想从这本日记里撕下一页借给他，但他脾气太臭了。我本想从这本日记里撕下一页借给他，但他脾气太臭了。我们再过半小时就要降落了，我快饿死了，美利坚航空上根本没有零食，除非你想花七块钱买个荒谬的东西。航空业到底怎么了？
Question mark, exclamation point. That was amazing, Angela. Oh, you guys. I loved Oh, you got it. I loved it. I loved it. Can you believe I wouldn't give the guy a piece of paper? He's like writing on his plane ticket. You're not going to give the airline $5 for headphones or $7 for a snack.
问号，感叹号。太精彩了，安吉拉。哦，天哪。我爱死...哦，你懂的。我爱死它了。我爱死它了。你能相信我不肯给那家伙一张纸吗？他居然在登机牌上写字。你既不肯花5美元买航空耳机，也不肯花7美元买零食。
You're not sharing your paper. I'm not going to spend $12 on things I need. No. Oh. Ridiculous. $. Oh, ridiculous. $7 for SNAP. I absolutely loved it. Well, there you go.
你连纸都不肯分给别人。我才不会把12美元花在我需要的东西上呢。不。哦。荒谬。美元。哦，荒谬。7美元买个零食。我绝对太喜欢了。好吧，就是这样。
That's my Angela's journal's updates. I will save some of our early years that I wrote about for the end of our run. That's all I got for FastFacts Lady. I could really just do a whole episode of you reading your journals. You know what this made me want to do? Is journal again when I travel? Because I use to always do. Me too. Yeah. It's such good character study. If you're a writer or an actor, it's great character study. I always love your messages when you've gotten off a plane because that's what they are. That's the description I get. You really paint a picture. All right,
这就是我的安吉拉日记最新进展。我要把一些我写的关于早期岁月的日记留到我们剧集完结时再读。女士们，我今天的快讯就到这里。我真的可以专门做一集节目听你读日记。你知道这让我想做什么吗？就是在旅行时重新开始写日记。因为我以前总是这么做。我也是。是的。这是很好的角色研究。如果你是一个演员或作家，这是极好的角色研究。我一直很喜欢你下飞机后发给我的信息，因为它们就是那样的。这就是我收到的描述。你真的描绘出了一幅画面。好了，
well, should we take a break? And then when we come back, does Stanley have a mustache? Oh, there's a hot debate. Well, the episode's going to start with Pam and Phyllis. They're passing around a card for everyone to sign, welcoming Stanley back from his tonsil surgery. I guess the card says, quote, glad they didn't mix up your tonsilectomy with a mustache ectomy. We get some Gymsass, he says, oh, that's not good. Met with some phyllisass, she's like, oh, because your jokes are all hilarious.
那我们要不要休息一下？等我们回来之后，斯坦利到底有没有胡子？哦，这可是一个激烈的争论。好吧，这一集将从帕姆和菲尔斯开始。她们在传阅一张卡片让大家签名，欢迎斯坦利做完扁桃体手术回来。我想卡片上写着，引述：“很高兴他们没有把你的扁桃体切除术跟胡子切除术搞混。”我们听到了一些吉姆式讽刺，他说，哦，这可不太妙。随之而来的是一些菲尔斯式讽刺，她说，哦，因为你的笑话都滑稽透了。
You know what, lady, this made me realize we really like a punny card on this show. Mm-hmm. Remember in the Alliance, Meredith got a card that said happy bird day? Yep. Do you have a memory of getting a real pun card? Because I do.
你知道吗，女士，这让我意识到我们真的很喜欢这出剧里那些双关语卡片。嗯哼。还记得在《联盟》那一集里，梅雷迪思收到了一张写着“生日快乐（bird day，谐音鸟日）”的卡片吗？对。你对收到真正的双关语卡片有什么记忆吗？因为我有。
No, we give my dad pun cards. Does he like a pun card? He loves a pun. He's a punner. There's one in every family. Mm-hmm. I am not the punner, but somehow I still get cards with puns.
不，我们会给我爸爸送双关语卡片。他喜欢双关语卡片吗？他超级喜欢双关语。他是个双关语达人。每个家庭都有这么一个人。嗯哼不知怎么的，我不是个爱玩双关语的人，但我还是经常收到带有双关语的卡片。
I got one time from a friend of mine that it was just a picture of a sofa and it said you're sofa king awesome Took me a second Clever Well Jim is going to question whether or not Stanley has a mustache. Yeah And everyone's like no he does have a mustache And everyone's like, no, he does have a mustache. Well, some people feel very strongly that he does. Some people feel like, no way he does not.
我有一次从一个朋友那里收到一张卡片，上面只有一张沙发（sofa）的照片，写着“你太（sofa）棒了（You're sofa king awesome，听起来像You're fucking awesome你太牛了）”。我反应了一会儿才明白。太机智了。好吧，吉姆要开始质疑斯坦利到底有没有胡子了。对。每个人都说，不，他确实有胡子。每个人都说，不，他确实有胡子。好吧，有些人坚信他有。有些人则认为，绝不可能，他绝对没有。
And then some people are waffling. I did break it down. Here's how the Dundermiflin bunch voted by show of hands. Team Stash are Pam Dwight Creed and Oscar. Team No Stash, Jim Phyllis Angela. Team Unsure about the stash, Kevin. I feel like Phyllis, Angela, team unsure about the stash, Kevin. I feel like Phyllis raises both hands. She has two hands up at the end.
还有一些人摇摆不定。我做了一个统计。邓德米夫林的众人举手表决结果如下。有胡子战队：帕姆、德怀特、克里德和奥斯卡。没胡子战队：吉姆、菲尔斯、安吉拉。对胡子持不确定态度战队：凯文。我觉得菲尔斯，对胡子持不确定态度战队：凯文。我觉得菲尔斯举了双手。最后她举了两只手。
Yes, that's true. She might be unsure. She might be in team unsure stash. I mean, Pam even draws a picture. She draws a mustache, Stanley, and a no mustache, Stanley. That didn't seem to help, but we did get a lot of mail about these drawings. Jocelyn V and St. George Utah, Millie P from Durham, North Carolina, and Zoe G from Irvine,
是的，确实如此。她可能很不确定。她可能在不确定胡子战队里。我是说，帕姆甚至还画了一幅画。她画了一个有胡子的斯坦利和一个没胡子的斯坦利。这似乎没什么帮助，但我们确实收到了很多关于这些画的信件。来自犹他州圣乔治的乔斯林·V、来自北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的米莉·P以及来自加利福尼亚州欧文的
California, all said Jenna in the cold open when everyone is trying to remember whether or not Stanley has a mustache. Pantross two pictures of Stanley in eight seconds. That's very funny. At 50 seconds, she is standing next to Phyllis, and at 58, she says, okay, and then holds up two full-page recognizable sketches of Stanley. In rewatching the scene, Pam's frantic faux-speed sketching in the background of Jim's line had me cracking up. That means she only had four seconds for each of those pictures. Who really drew
佐伊·G都说，珍妮，在冷场开场时，当大家都在试图回想斯坦利到底有没有胡子时。帕姆在八秒钟内画了两幅斯坦利的画。这太搞笑了。在第50秒时，她正站在菲尔斯旁边，而在第58秒时，她说，好了，然后举起了两张画着清晰可辨的斯坦利的正反全页素描。在重看这一幕时，帕姆在吉姆的台词背景里疯狂地进行伪快速素描，把我笑死。这意味着她每幅画只有四秒钟的时间。到底是谁画的
those pictures? Were you directed to draw really fast? Please tell us everything you remember about this scene. Well, Jocelyn, Millie, and Zoe, I have a curveball to throw at you. What if Pam has sketched everyone in the office and keeps them in her desk drawer? That's something something Dwight would do. I know. Because he's gonna need a wand in the poster and a moment. But Pam has drawn Dwight. This is true.
那些画？剧组是不是要求你画得非常快？请告诉我们你对这一幕的所有记忆。好吧，乔斯林、米莉和佐伊，我有一个难题要抛给你们。如果帕姆把办公室里的每个人都画了一遍，并把它们藏在办公桌抽屉里呢？那绝对是德怀特会做的事。我知道。因为他以后做海报和开纪念会时会用得着。不过帕姆确实画过德怀特。这倒也是。
Well, first of all, I did not draw those pictures. They were preset for me. I'm pretending to draw feverishly. But there were a few lines of dialogue in the scene that got cut out. The original script allowed me more time to draw these pictures. So in the scene, Pam says, Phyllis would know if Stanley has a mustache, she sits across from him every day. And Phyllis is like, oh my god, I don't know. Now I think he doesn't. And Pam
好吧，首先，我并没有画那些画。它们是提前为我准备好的。我只是假装在疯狂地画画。但这一幕里其实有几行台词被剪掉了。最初的剧本允许我有更多时间来画这些画。所以在这一场戏里，帕姆说，菲尔斯应该知道斯坦利有没有胡子，她每天都坐在他对面。然后菲尔斯说，哦天哪，我不知道。现在我觉得他没有。接着帕姆
says, oh, come on, Phyllis, the whole card depends on this. So at this point, Jim would have thrown to Kevin. He would have said, Kevin does Stanley have a mustache. And Kevin would have said, okay, I'm picturing him. Now I'm asking him if he has a mustache. He's not answering guys. And also, Creed would have said, when I close my eyes, I see a mustache, and a white beard, and a red suit.
说，哦得了吧，菲尔斯，整张卡片都指望这个呢。所以在这个时候，吉姆本该把话题抛给凯文。他会说，凯文，斯坦利有胡子吗？然后凯文会说，好吧，我在脑海中想象他。现在我在问他有没有胡子。他没有回答我，伙计们。而且，克里德本该说，当我闭上眼睛时，我看到了一把胡子，还有一顶白胡子，一件红衣服。
He's my father, and he's asking me to guide his sleigh tonight. So- Don't ask Creed ever. Don't ask Creed. The script did say that I was supposed to hold up to quote hastily made drawings. It also noted that the one with the mustache should be a giant mustache, not an accurate mustache.
他是我的父亲，他正要求我今晚帮他驾雪橇。所以——永远不要问克里德。永远不要问克里德。剧本确实写着我应该举起两张号称“仓促完成的画作”。上面还标注了有胡子的那张应该画一个巨大的胡子，而不是一个精确的胡子。
So there you have it, that's what happened. I had more time, but they kind of snipped some of it away. You had more time, but still not enough to do those two drawings, in my opinion, but that's okay, it's a little bit of TV magic. I feel like I would have doubled my time. But that's okay, it's a little bit of TV magic. I feel like I would have doubled my time. Do you think 16 seconds is enough time?
所以这就是真相，事情就是这样。我本来有更多时间，但在我看来，依然不足以完成那两幅画，不过没关系，这就是一点电视魔法。我觉得我本可以把时间翻倍。不过没关系，这就是一点电视魔法。我觉得我本可以把时间翻倍。你觉得16秒够时间吗？
It might have been more, because Kevin does a whole visualization thing. I don't know. Well, I guess it depends on your skill set because I would have needed all day to do that. Well Gabe is very excited because Stanley is arriving and as Stanley walks in, Gabe covers his face, so we can't see and then does sort of like tada and he does in fact have a mustache.
时间可能更多一点，因为凯文做了一整套可视化想象。我不知道。好吧，我想这取决于你的技能水平，因为我需要一整天的时间才能做到这一点。好吧，盖布非常兴奋，因为斯坦利要来了，当斯坦利走进来时，盖布捂住了自己的脸，这样我们就看不见，然后做了一个类似“哒哒”的手势，他确实留着胡子。
We got a fan question from Veronica R and Park City Illinois who said, where did the idea of Stanley having or not having a mustache come from? Was this based on a real conversation about whether or not Leslie had a mustache? Well, Veronica, we got to trade some messages with our writers Steve Healy, and he said that this idea came up in the writers room. He said it was either Mindy or BJ who pointed out that it was really hard to visualize whether or not Leslie had a mustache or not. He said that the writer's room did have a debate, and only about 85% felt 100% sure he had one. I thought this was so relatable when Steve shared this with us because how many times are you sitting around
我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州帕克城维罗妮卡·R的粉丝提问，她说，斯坦利有无胡子这个想法是从哪里来的？这是否基于关于莱斯利是否留胡子的真实对话？好吧，维罗妮卡，我们得以和我们的编剧史蒂夫·希利交流了一些信息，他说这个想法是在编剧室里诞生的。他说要么是明迪，要么是BJ指出，要想象莱斯利到底有没有胡子真的很难。他说编剧室确实为此进行了一场辩论，只有大约85%的人百分之百确信他有胡子。当史蒂夫与我们分享这一点时，我觉得太有共鸣了，因为有多少次你坐在一起
like at dinner with friends that you've known forever? And someone's like, oh yeah, you know, Jenna has blue eyes and they're like, no she doesn't. Like what are you talking about? She has blue eyes and then that whole debate starts. Like, yeah, it happens. When I was watching the cold open, did it make you second guess?
比如和认识了很久的朋友一起吃晚餐？然后有人说，哦对了，你知道的，珍妮有蓝眼睛，而另一个人说，不，她没有。就像你在说什么呢？她有蓝眼睛，然后整场辩论就开始了。就像，是的，这经常发生。当我看着冷场开场时，它有没有让你产生二次猜测？
It did. Me too. I was not sure. I was like, wait, no, he does. He does. He does. He does, yes. But you just plant that seed of doubt
确实有。我也是。我当时很不确定。我心想，等等，不对，他有。他有的。他有的。他有，是的。但你只要种下一颗怀疑的种子，
and then you're sure. Yeah. Well Steve was so gracious. We reached out to him with a few questions and then you're sure. Yeah. Well, Steve was so gracious. We reached out to him with a few questions and we're going to sprinkle those in. Well, I've got something to share from him right off the top after the opening credits. We got a fan mill flurry again about Nelly
然后你就不确定了。是的。好吧，史蒂夫真是太好了。我们带着几个问题联系了他，然后你就不确定了。是的。好吧，史蒂夫真是太好了。我们带着几个问题联系了他，我们会在节目中穿插这些内容。好吧，在片头曲过后，我马上有关于他的内容要分享。我们又收到了一阵关于内莉
not being featured as the manager. Yes, I noticed that too. I thought for sure this opening credits would have something with her on her desk. But no. I asked you, he'll be about it. I said, did the writers have an arc in mind for Nelly as manager? And he said there was not a clear plan.
没有被安排担任经理的粉丝来信狂潮。是的，我也注意到了。我原本以为这次的片头曲里会有一些她坐在办公桌前的画面。然而并没有。我问过他关于这事。我说，编剧们对内莉担任经理有一个宏大的故事线规划吗？他说并没有一个清晰的计划。
With the other managers, it was sort of pre-planned. They knew it was going to be an arc. He said they were kind of at this point writing week to week. Oh, geez. Yeah. Oh my gosh. He said he did remember talking to Catherine Tate one day at lunch early on, and she had shared that she found California kind of odd compared to London. So they did try to incorporate some of that kind of fish out of water stuff into her character. So that was something that they had pre-planned for her rival to Scranton. But they didn't know about Nellie's position within the Dundermiffland, like hierarchy. Or how long she would be staying manager. They were kind of deciding week to week. How that would go.
对于其他经理，这基本上是预先规划好的。他们知道这将是一条故事线。他说他们在这个阶段基本上是按周写剧本的。哦，天哪。是的。哦天哪。他说他确实记得早期有一次在午餐时跟凯瑟琳·泰特聊过，她曾分享说，与伦敦相比，她觉得加利福尼亚有点古怪。所以他们确实试图将那种“局外人”的元素融入到她的角色中。所以这是他们为她空降斯克兰顿提前规划好的一部分。但他们并不知道内莉在邓德米夫林层级中的地位。也不知道她会当多久的经理。他们基本上是按周决定剧情的走向。
Got it. Well, Robert California is going to arrive and he's not greeted by anyone because Aaron is in Florida. He sneaks up behind Pam, who has headphones on. She's drinking her coffee, she's rocking out. Yeah, she is listening to Drake featuring Swiss beats. I have an audio clip. Would you like to hear what Pam was warming up? Wait, I know what she was warming up to, but I think we should all hear it.
原来如此。好吧，罗伯特·加利福尼亚即将抵达，没有人迎接他，因为埃德温在佛罗里达。他偷偷走到戴着耳机的帕姆身后。她正喝着咖啡，陶醉在音乐中。是的，她听的是德雷克featuring斯威士·比茨。我有一段音频剪辑。你想听听帕姆是在热身什么吗？等等，我知道她在为什么热身，但我觉得我们都应该听听。
It's fancy. Oh, I know. I know what she was warming up to, but I think we should all hear it. It's fancy. Oh, I know. Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, head. Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh?
这歌很别致。哦，我懂。我知道她在为什么热身，但我觉得我们都应该听听。这歌很别致。哦，我知道。哦，上，上，上，上，上，上，上，上，上，上，头。你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？
Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? They're done here, done everything they did. They're done here, done everything they, oh, you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? All right, that fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh?
你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？他们在这儿做完了，做完了他们所做的一切。他们在这儿做完了，做完了他们所有，哦，你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？好吧，那首很别致，哈？你很别致，哈？
All right, that's how Pam warms up for a day of work. Yeah. It got me thinking, do you warm up with music, and I texted you, I said, I think we should each think about this, and we should play our warm up for the day music. 100%. You do? Oh, yeah. And sometimes if I think the kids,
好吧，这就是帕姆为一天的工作做热身的方式。这让我开始思考，你平时会用音乐来热身吗？我还发短信给你说，我觉得我们应该各自考虑一下这个，然后我们应该播放我们一天的工作热身音乐。百分之百。你也会？哦，是的。有时候如果我觉得孩子们，
you know, I have teenagers now need to pick me up on the way to school Maybe they got a big test. Maybe they got to get amped up. I am I do the carpool DJ stuff. I play some songs to get us going Oh wow you got your carpool playlist, but I'm it's the mom version. I don't know if it's exactly There's stuff. I have a good mix. I really do. Okay, what does your main go to? I really have to. Okay. That I love. I love Alicia Keys' girl on fire.
你知道的，我现在有青少年了，在上学路上需要振作一下精神也许他们有个大考试。也许他们需要嗨起来。我是我负责当拼车DJ。我会放一些歌来调动气氛。哦，哇，你还有你的拼车播放列表，不过这是妈妈版的。我不知道这到底是不是大家听的。里面有各种好歌。我确实准备了一个很棒的混音歌单。好吧，你最常听的主打歌是什么？我真的必须要放。好吧。我最爱的。我超爱Alicia Keys（艾莉西亚·凯斯）的《Girl on Fire》。
Mm-hmm. And I love a little Joan Jett. Hey, I'm a kid of the 70s, and Joan Jett really wakes me up. Like the song, Bad Reputation. Mm-hmm, I love it. Do you wanna hear a little bit of it? Yeah, let's hear it. reputation. I love it. Do you want to hear a little bit of it? Yeah, let's hear it.
嗯哼。我还超爱一点Joan Jett（琼·杰特）。嘿，我是70年代的孩子，Joan Jett真的能唤醒我。就像那首歌，《坏名声（Bad Reputation）》。嗯哼，我超爱。你想听一小段吗？好吧，让我们听听。声誉。我超爱。你想听一小段吗？好吧，让我们听听。
I love it. I just added it to my playlist. Isn't it a good one? That is so good. You know, Lee wrote and directed a movie called Ordinary World, stars Billy Joe Armstrong and Joan Jett makes a cameo in it. It was also right around the time that both of them were inducted into the rock and roll Hall of Fame in the same year, like the same ceremony. Mm-hmm. Never got to meet her. All of this, right?
我太喜欢了。我刚把它加到我的播放列表里。这不是一首好歌吗？这真的太棒了。你知道的，李曾经编剧并导演过一部名为《普通世界》的电影，比利·乔·阿姆斯，强主演，琼·杰特还在里面客串了。这也正值他们俩在同一年入选摇滚名人堂的时期，就像是同一场典礼。嗯哼。我从没机会见到她。所有这些，对吧？
Lee has met her, worked with her. Rock and roll, man. Love her. Love her. Well, Jenna, what about you? Well, as you know, I mostly drive in silence. I know. I know this. But sometimes in the mornings, if I'm dragging or something, my go-to warm-up, pick me up, is the musical Hamilton. Oh, I love Hamilton. That's on our mix too. I will always end with the same song like as I'm getting close to home, I'll switch so that I end on room where it happened. Oh, I love it.
李见过她，和她合作过。摇滚乐，老兄。我爱死她了。爱死她了。好吧，珍妮，你呢？好吧，如你所知，我开车时大部分时间都在保持安静。我知道。我当然知道这点。但有时在早晨，如果我感到精疲力竭或者状态不佳，我的首选热身、提神音乐就是音乐剧《汉密尔顿》。哦，我爱惨了《汉密尔顿》。那也在我们的混音列表里。我总是以同一首歌结尾，当快要到家时，我会切换歌曲，以便以《故事发生的地方（Room Where It Happens）》结尾。哦，我太喜欢了。
That's my major pump me up and I have a clip. Yeah about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. No one really knows how the game is played. The art of the trade, the sausage, it's made. We just assume that it happens. But no one else is in the room where it happens. I just love it. I love it so much. I've seen Hamilton on Broadway three times since it came out.
那是我的重磅提神曲，我有一段剪辑。是的，关于我们，我们正在故事发生的地方。不用担心我们，我们正在故事发生的地方。不用担心我们，我们正在故事发生的地方。不用担心我们，我们正在故事发生的地方。没有人真正知道游戏是怎么玩的。交易的艺术，香肠是怎么做出来的。我们只是以为它自然就发生了。但没有其他人身处故事发生的地方。我太喜欢了。我真的爱惨了。自从它上映以来，我已经去百老汇看《汉密尔顿》三次了。
Once with the very original cast, the OG, the OG, I had to get the super expensive, terrible seats. You couldn't get a ticket. And I've seen it twice since with the current cast. The energy in the theater for this whole show is like I don't even know how to describe it. It's a body buzz. It is. It is. Especially now that pretty much everyone who goes knows all the songs. Yeah. And I've seen different people play all the different parts and it just delivers every time. Every time.
有一次是最初的原班人马，原汁原味的那种，我不得不买那些超级贵、位置极差的票。你根本买不到票。后来我又看了两次现在的演员阵容。整场演出在剧院里的那种能量，我都不知道该怎么形容。那是一种全身心的震撼。真的是这样。尤其是现在，几乎所有去看的观众都知道所有的歌。对啊。而且我看到过不同的人演过所有的角色，每一次都那么精彩。每一次。
I love it too. I have to say also on my mix are a few songs from the musical six. Oh, yes! Yes, and I also love, if you don't have this on your playlist, I'm Every Woman by Shaka Khan. Sure.
我也很喜欢。我还要说，在我的混音列表里还有音乐剧《六位王后》里的几首歌。哦，太棒了！对，而且我也很喜欢——如果你的播放列表里没有这首的话——那就是查卡·库恩（Shaka Khan）的《我是每一个女人》（I'm Every Woman）。当然。
Yeah, it's so good. Well now I feel pumped up actually. Me too. I feel especially pumped for the rest of this podcast. Robert gets distracted from his conversation with Pam because Nelly is going to finally arrive. He's giving Pam a speech about how the best work is done between 9 and 10 a.m. Nelly's going to walk in the door at 9.50. Yeah. She's going to say she hits snooze multiple times and finally woke up 10 minutes ago. There's a lot of back and forth between Nelly and Robert
对，这首歌太棒了。好了，现在我感觉整个人都兴奋起来了。我也是。我觉得接下来这期播客让我格外兴奋。罗伯特和潘聊天时分了心，因为娜莉终于要到了。他正在对潘发表一番长篇大论，谈论最好的工作是如何在上午9点到10点之间完成的。而娜莉将在9点50分走进大门。对啊。她会说她按了好几次贪睡闹钟，结果10分钟前才刚醒。娜莉和罗伯特之间有很多来回的对话
and Angela and Pam are clocking it all. They are the biggest eye rolls. I mean, is that one of your eye roll memes, Angela, because it's not, it should be. It means to be. It's an IRL that I do kind of a weird thing with my mouth like, burr. It is delicious. I wrote a lot of big acting choices in this episode.
而安吉拉和潘把这一切都看在眼里。她们翻了个大大的白眼。我是说，安吉拉，这算是你的白眼表情包吗？因为如果不是的话，那就该是。它就该是。这是一个我会在现实生活中做出的奇怪嘴部动作，就像是，呼。这太好玩了。我在这一集里写了很多重大的表演选择。
That's what I wrote, too. I want to do a fan catch here for you from Sophia D. and Hamilton, Ontario, Canada, who said that it, two minutes and 20 seconds, Nelly mentions that she snoozes her alarm clock in nine minute increments. Sophia said, this made me wonder why the snooze feature on alarm clocks are nine minutes long because it seems like such a random number.
我也是这么写的。我这里要为你们分享一个来自安大略省哈密尔顿市的索菲亚·D.的粉丝发现，她说在2分20秒的时候，娜莉提到她的闹钟贪睡功能是每9分钟增加一次。索菲亚说，这让她很好奇为什么闹钟上的贪睡功能是9分钟长，因为这听起来像是一个非常随意的数字。
So I did a mini deep dive. Oh, cool. Sophia's gonna tell us. Thank you, Sophia. I guess when they made the original alarm clocks, it wasn't possible to get the gear teeth to line up to make for an exact 10 minutes. So they chose nine instead,
所以我做了一次迷你的深度调查。哦，太酷了。索菲亚要告诉我们了。谢谢你，索菲亚。我猜当年制作最初的闹钟时，齿轮无法完美对齐来正好定出10分钟的时间。所以他们只好选择了9分钟，
but now iPhones and other clocks just carry on the tradition. Even though now you could get a snooze of 10 minutes, should we be able to choose our snooze? Yeah, you can. You can choose. Now I can choose my snooze? Well, you can set a timer, I guess.
但现在苹果手机和其他时钟只是延续了这个传统。尽管现在你完全可以把贪睡设置成10分钟，难道我们不应该能选择自己的贪睡时间吗？对，你可以。你可以选择。现在我可以选择我的贪睡时间了？嗯，我想你可以设置一个定时器。
What do you mean set a timer? Like you can say, I want to sleep five more minutes. You can? Yes. Clearly someone who hits snooze. Wait, so when I hit snooze, do I preset my snooze time? Because I don't want it in the moment, I'll wake up if I'm like having to... Yeah, no, I don't know about that. I just like do like the wheel, like I just spin it. I'm like, yeah, okay, 10 minutes.
你说的设置定时器是什么意思？就像你可以说，我想再睡五分钟。可以吗？可以。这显然是个经常按贪睡键的人。等等，所以当我按贪睡键时，我是预先设置好了我的贪睡时间吗？因为我不想在那个当下……如果我必须去……对，不，我不知道这个。我只会用那个转盘一样的功能，就像我只是拨一下它。我会想，行吧，10分钟。
I know that there's someone out there who knows how to operate their phone and they're dying because we are asking questions that they're answering. I think we do this often, lady. I think we have our moments and they're like, oh my gosh, you are our two old ants. Well, if you could change your snooze time from nine minutes to something else, would you? Probably not. I would maybe do seven. Seven, lucky number seven. You know why? Because I want a snooze twice,
我知道一定有人知道怎么操作他们的手机，而且他们现在急得要死，因为我们正在问一些他们全都知道答案的问题。我觉得我们经常这样，姐妹。我觉得我们总有这种时刻，然后大家就会觉得，天哪，你们俩简直就是老古董。好吧，如果你能把你的贪睡时间从9分钟改成别的，你会吗？大概不会吧。我可能会改成7分钟。7，幸运数字7。你知道为什么吗？因为我想按两次贪睡键，
but 18 minutes feels like too much snoozing, but maybe 14 minutes feels right to me. The fact that you're breaking it down like that tells me you're not a real professional snoozer. No, I very rarely snooze. Uh-huh. I don't see the point. I wait to have my alarm go off until the very last minute.
但18分钟感觉贪睡时间太长了，不过也许14分钟对我来说刚刚好。你居然能把时间分析得这么透彻，这说明你根本不是一个真正的专业贪睡大王。不，我很少按贪睡键。嗯哼。我觉得没意义。我总是等到闹钟响起的最后那一分钟才起床。
Well, Nelly is a snoozer. Wack, she hits it a lot. Robert says he thinks there's something more going on with her than just a lack of willpower, you know? Mm-hmm. And he's going to have Jim and Dwight help her move and get settled. He's concerned about her. And he's going to have Jim and Dwight help her move and get settled. He's concerned about her. Not only that, he's going to tell everyone in the office that at the end of the day, we're going to have a welcome party for her. So start planning.
好吧，娜莉可是个贪睡大王。天哪，她按得可频繁了。罗伯特说他觉得她身上除了缺乏意志力之外，还有别的问题，你知道吗？嗯哼。他打算让吉姆和德怀特帮她搬家并安顿下来。他很关心她。不仅如此，他还打算告诉办公室里的每个人，说今天结束时我们要为她举办一个欢迎派对。所以大家开始策划吧。
Yeah, Robert is so invested in Nellie and her happiness. You know, when we were talking to Steve Healy our writer, he said in an early version of the episode, this episode was called, help me not to do her. What? Yes, it's not an episode. And it was all about Robert California trying to resist his attraction with Nelly and ordering Jim to help him with that temptation.
对，罗伯特对娜莉以及她的幸福如此上心。你知道的，当我们和我们的编剧史蒂夫·希利聊天时，他说在这一集早期的一个版本里，这一集曾被叫做“帮帮我，别迷恋她”。什么？对，这不是一集。而且内容全都是关于罗伯特·加利福尼亚试图抵抗他对娜莉的吸引力，并命令吉姆帮他抵挡这种诱惑。
And then Steve put in all caps wisely, we went in another direction. I love that we get these nuggets from our writers. I know. That's incredible. And now we have some rapid fire back-to-back talking heads as Pam Jim, Pam Jim. They're like, why are we throwing a party for someone who's horrible?
然后史蒂夫用大写字母明智地写道：“我们换了个方向。”我太喜欢我们能从编剧那里听到这些幕后小花絮了。我也是。这太不可思议了。现在我们有一些节奏明快的连续访谈镜头，是潘和吉姆，潘和吉姆。他们俩就像是在说，为什么我们要为这样一个讨厌的人办派对？
Why is Nelly even here? Why is she here? There also would have been a Darryl talking head. OK. It was in the shooting draft, and it would have said, Andy took off to get Aaron. Nelly showed up to take Andy's job. Robert has a crush on Nelly.
为什么娜莉会在这儿？她为什么在这儿？这里本来还有一个达里尔的访谈镜头。好吧。它在拍摄剧本里，台词大概是：安迪请假去接艾琳了。娜莉出现来接替安迪的工作。罗伯特对娜莉有好感。
And Darrell's new French cuff shirt goes unnoticed. Aw, Darrell. But then there were two candy bag ults that really made me laugh. Okay, the top of the talking head is the same, but it ends with this. And Darrell's got a front row seat, which he would happily give up to just about anybody.
而达里尔崭新的法式叠袖衬衫却无人问津。哦，达里尔。但后来有两个糖果包彩蛋真的把我逗笑了。好吧，访谈的前半部分是一样的，但结尾变成了这样。而达里尔坐在前排观看，他很乐意把这个位置让给任何人。
And then his other candy bag all it was. And who's selling paper? That would be nobody. Oh, I love that line. I know. Now, we are going to join Andy and Aaron. They're in the car. They're driving back to Scranton.
然后他的另一个糖果包彩蛋是。还有谁在卖纸？那可是一个都没有。哦，我太喜欢这句台词了。我知道。现在，我们要加入安迪和艾琳的行列。他们在车里。他们正开车回斯克兰顿。
They're so cute. Taylor M. from Brentswick, Georgia said, I love the callback to the season six episode murder where Andy asked Aaron out on a date in Savannah while as their murder mystery characters and now they're back together again and they're wearing their Savannah t-shirts. They finally had their date in Savannah. Oh, that's so true.
他们太可爱了。来自佐治亚州布伦斯维克的泰勒·M.说，我太喜欢致敬第六季《谋杀》那一集了，当时安迪在萨凡纳扮演他们的谋杀悬疑角色时约艾琳出去约会，现在他们又重新在一起了，而且他们还穿着萨凡纳的T恤。他们终于在萨凡纳约会了。哦，太真实了。
Such a cute callback. Cute callback, they're making up songs, you guys. Andy's gonna sing two crazy kids on the journey of life. Aaron's gonna chime in, go into Pennsylvania. All the hope in the world these two. They're gonna make a pit stop. They're gonna have a little lunch and they're gonna explain that they're on their way to Jessica's parents' cabin in Southern Pennsylvania. Andy thinks this is gonna be a good place to let her down easy. Her parents' cabin. Pennsylvania Andy thinks this is gonna be a good place to let her down easy.
真是个可爱的呼应。可爱的呼应，他们俩在即兴编歌呢，伙计们。安迪要唱“生活旅程中的两个疯狂小孩”。艾琳会接着唱，“前往宾夕法尼亚”。这两人充满了对世界的希望。他们要中途停车。他们要吃个午饭，还要解释说他们正在去杰西卡父母位于宾夕法尼亚州南部的小木屋的路上。安迪觉得这是个好地方，可以好聚好散。她父母的小木屋。宾夕法尼亚安迪觉得这是个好地方，可以好聚好散。
Her parents cabin. There are so many moments in this episode where I thought, you know what? Andy and Erin belong together. I'm changing my mind. Jessica, you know what? You narrowly escaped. It's so true.
她父母的小木屋。这一集里有太多次我都觉得，你知道吗？安迪和艾琳才是一对。我改变主意了。杰西卡，你知道吗？你真是死里逃生。太真实了。
I have the location of the park. We got some mail. People were curious. This is a little bit of movie magic because this scene in the park, quote unquote, park was shot on the same property as the cabin. Oh, it was kind of right next to the cabin. That's perfect. Yeah. It's a place called Canyon Ranch in 1,000 Oaks. Aaron and Andy get back in the car, get on the road. Andy thinks maybe it's time for a little smoochy smooch,
我知道公园的地点。我们收到了一些邮件。大家都很好奇。这其实有点电影魔术的意思，因为这个所谓的“公园”场景其实和那个小木屋是在同一处地产上拍摄的。哦，它就挨着小木屋。太完美了。对。那是奥克斯千橡市一个叫卡峡谷牧场（Canyon Ranch）的地方。艾琳和安迪回到车上，再次上路。安迪觉得也许是时候来个小小的亲亲了，
but Aaron shuts that down. Uh-uh, buddy, not till you're officially single. Mm-hmm. So they got a wait. Yeah. We don't care. I know, we were team Jessica. So this episode made us angry.
但艾琳拒绝了。想得美，伙计，在你正式恢复单身之前休想。嗯哼。所以他们得等等。好吧。我们才不在乎呢。我知道，我们以前是杰西卡党。所以这一集把我们气坏了。
It did, although I'm gonna have a moment where I turn on Jessica a little later. Okay, okay. So I just so everyone knows I can turn on her. Okay, I think I know the moment. All right, and I think they needed it because I think we had to start rooting for Andy and Erin. Up next in the break room, I titled this scene,
确实如此，尽管过一会儿我会有一刻开始有点讨厌杰西卡了。好吧，好吧。所以为了让大家知道，我是会开始讨厌她的。好吧，我想我知道是哪个时刻了。好吧，我觉得他们需要这个，因为我觉得我们得开始支持安迪和艾琳了。接下来是在休息室，我给这个场景起名叫，
Mean Girls in the Break Room. And if anyone wants to write a pop song version about it and tag us, I will gladly play it. Phyllis Oscar-Pam and Angela are really gripping about having to throw a party for Nelly. And then Phyllis proposes maybe on purpose. They throw a bad party, like a really crappy party. Angela's like, ooh, maybe we should have the party right here in the break room and then they giggle. Phyllis says order carrot cake, they're laughing so hard.
休息室里的辣妹。如果有人想围绕这个写一首流行歌并艾特我们，我很乐意播放它。菲莉丝、奥斯卡、潘和安吉拉真的在抱怨不得不为娜莉办派对。然后菲莉丝提议说，也许可以故意。办一个糟糕的派对，办一个真的很烂的派对。安吉拉说，哦，也许我们应该把派对直接开在这个休息室里，然后她们咯咯笑了起来。菲莉丝说订个胡萝卜蛋糕吧，她们笑得前仰后合。
Mm-hmm. I have 90 million catches from the scene. Let's go. Number one, when did Oscar join the PPC? I don't know. Okay. Number two is a fan question from Hannah G. in Scotland who says, I need a breakdown of Angela's hair in this episode. She has a curly bouncy ponytail which seems very fancy for Angela.
嗯哼。我从这个场景里挑出了9000万个彩蛋。我们开始吧。第一，奥斯卡是什么时候加入党建委员会（PPC）的？我不知道。好吧。第二是一个来自苏格兰的汉娜·G.的粉丝提问，她说，我需要详细解析安吉拉在这一集里的发型。她扎了一个卷曲蓬松的高马尾，这对于安吉拉来说似乎太时髦了。
Was there an event going on this week that she had her hair this way or did you guys just decide to change it up? I noticed it too, and what is with your poofy? It is not flat ironed. No, it is leftover event hair. Okay. 100% and then Kim had to match it every day because we always got excited when I had leftover event hair.
这周有什么活动所以她才弄成这样，还是你们决定换个造型？我也注意到了，你那个蓬松的发型是怎么回事？它可不是用夹板夹直的。不，这是活动剩下的发型。好吧。百分之百是的，然后金每天都得跟这个发型保持一致，因为每当我留着活动剩下的发型时，我们总是会很兴奋。
Also did you catch at five minutes, 28 seconds, that my ponytail holder is the exact same color as my hair? I thought it was your hair. No. I thought they did a wrap around. No, it's a ponytail holder is the exact same color as my hair. I thought it was your hair. I thought they did a wrap around. No, it's a ponytail holder. I have a catch at five minutes and 30 seconds. What's that? I am not wearing my Pam engagement ring and wedding band.
还有，你有没有发现在5分28秒的时候，我的发圈颜色跟我的头发颜色一模一样？我还以为那是你的头发。不是。我还以为他们编进去了。不，那是发圈，颜色跟我头发一模一样。我还以为那是你的头发。我还以为他们编进去了。不，是个发圈。我发现了一个5分30秒时的彩蛋。是什么？我没有戴着潘的订婚戒指和结婚戒指。
I'm wearing a different ring. It looks like someone wore it home and left it at home. I don't know what I did. That would happen. Sometimes we would just leave set and I was like, oh no, I'm wearing Angela's earrings and her rings. Yeah, the wardrobe department had doubles
我戴的是另一枚戒指。看起来就像是有人把它戴回家然后忘在家了。我不知道我做了什么。这种事会发生。有时我们就会把道具留在片场，然后我会想，哦不，我戴着安吉拉的耳环和戒指。对，服装部有
of everything for me for earrings and necklaces because I would do that so often. And then you know, you take them off at night to shower and you tell yourself, I'm gonna put this on in the morning. I'm gonna put this on in the morning. And then you leave. And now like Jenna, what happened? I also have a fan catch from Brenton A. in Marin County, California, who said, I have a St. Louis catch at four minutes and 41 seconds.
我所有耳环和项链的双份道具，因为我经常这么干。然后你知道的，你晚上摘下来洗澡，你会告诉自己，我早上会把它戴上的。我早上会把它戴上的。然后你就忘了。现在就像是：珍娜，发生什么事了？我还有一个来自加利福尼亚州马林县的布伦顿·A.的粉丝彩蛋，他说，我在4分41秒发现了一个圣路易斯口音彩蛋。
Phyllis proposes the idea of artoring some carrot cake. Arder. It falls right in line with popcorn and that's a big arder. She does. She wants to art her some carrot cake. Those are my catches. Every time you guys catch Phyllis having a St. Louis accent is one of my favorite things. I agree. Well lady, let's take a break because when we get back we're going to be Holland cube. Yeah, we should rest up. Mm-hmm. We are back and before we haul some cube, Andy and Erin are going to do some breakup scenarios in the car. Get a little role play. We had a fan question from Mallory C in Durham, North Carolina, who said, in the scene where Andy and Aaron are practicing for Andy's breakup with Jessica,
菲莉丝提议去订（artor）一些胡萝卜蛋糕。订（arder）。这跟爆米花（popcurn）如出一辙，是个大错字（arder）。她确实这么说了。她想去订（artor）一些胡萝卜蛋糕。这就是我的彩蛋。每次你们抓到菲莉丝带有圣路易斯口音，都是我最喜欢的事情之一。我同意。好吧，各位，我们休息一下，因为回来后我们要去“搬大件（haul some cube）”了。对，我们该休息一下。嗯哼。我们回来了，在去“搬大件”之前，安迪和艾琳要在车里模拟一些分手场景。来点角色扮演。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的 Mallory C 的粉丝提问，她说，在安迪和艾琳为安迪和杰西卡的分手进行排练的场景中，
it looks like Ed broke and genuinely laughed when Ellie said, what is it I didn't sleep all last night? Was that scripted? Mallory it was not. It was improvised. I think they just let them go. They 100% just let them go. They 100% just let them go. If you are wondering where we shot the driving scenes, Wonder No More, first of all, Ed was not driving. We hooked up the car to a dolly
看起来埃德（Ed）笑场了，当娜莉说“怎么了，我昨晚一夜没睡？”时他是真笑了。那是剧本里的吗？马洛里，那不是。那是即兴发挥。我觉得他们就是让他们随便演。他们百分之百就是让演员自由发挥了。他们百分之百就是让演员自由发挥了。如果你想知道我们在哪里拍摄的开车场景，那就不用猜了，首先，开车的人不是埃德。我们把车挂在了一个平板车上，
and it was pulled by an insert car that's lingo for like a flatbed truck. And in the back of the truck, we have all our crew, we have camera sound director, assistant director. My dad had a flatbed truck and in the back of the truck we have all our crew, we have camera sound director, assistant director. My dad had a flatbed truck. Did he ever pull a picture car? That's Lingo for he didn't. The car the actors are in. He pulled a lot of horse trailer. Sure. Farming equipment. But he also loaded up a bunch of my stuff and drove the flatbed truck with a trailer attached to it, and that's how I moved to LA. How much stuff did you take?
由一辆“插入车”（一种平板卡车的行业术语）拉着。在卡车后面，坐着我们所有的剧组人员，有摄像、录音、导演、助理导演。我爸爸曾有一辆平板卡车。他在后面载过剧组吗？那是说他没有。演员坐的那辆车。他拉过很多马匹拖车。当然。农用设备。但他还装载过我的一堆东西，开着挂着拖车平板卡车，我就是这么搬去洛杉矶的。你带了多少东西？
You had your stuff in the flatbed and in a trailer behind it? The trailer behind it? The truck is pretty small, pretty short, but he also had an extended trailer he would attach to it. But I moved here with just a suitcase, and I lived out of a suitcase, and then finally my mom was like, Bill, load up, we're gonna bring you some furniture. Oh, that was really nice.
你的东西放在平板卡车上，后面还挂着个拖车？后面的拖车？那辆卡车挺小的，挺短的，但他还带了一个可以挂在后面的加长拖车。不过我来这里时只带了一个手提箱，我靠一个手提箱过日子，最后我妈妈说，比尔，装车，我们要给你带点家具来。哦，那太好了。
I know. Well, this flatbed was large. I have a picture of it. We got the flatbed truck. We've attached a car to it. We also had a bunch of precision drivers who drive around the picture car so that everything stays really consistent. You'll notice the car's drive at the exact same
我知道。好吧，这个平板车很大。我有它的照片。我们弄到了这辆平板卡车。我们在上面固定了一辆车。我们还请了一群专业的特技司机，他们开着车围着这辆主体车转，这样一切都能保持高度一致。你会发现车子开得完全是同一个
speed. There's not a lot of passing. Steve Healey said that getting all these driving scenes was way more complicated than he realized, because he was on set. The writer would always be on set. They were always more complicated. Always more complicated. It's a lot of moving parts.
速度。没有多少超车的镜头。史蒂夫·希利说过，拍所有这些开车场景比他想象的要复杂得多，因为他在现场。编剧总是会在现场。这些拍摄总是更复杂。总是更复杂。有太多移动的部件了。
And we shot this all on a real highway. I mean, I guess, obviously, right? We didn't build a highway. That should have gone without saying. We've done it before. We did it for Pam and Jim's engagement, but we did not do it this time. No, real road. Now everyone, we're going to haul some cube. Thank God I've been waiting to haul cube. I love this expression. I want to start saying it. I'm hauling cube. Every time I move from now on, I'm going to haul cube. I'm going to haul cube. I love this expression. I want to start saying it. I'm Hall and cube. Every time I move from now on, I'm going to Hall cube. I'm going to Hall cube. How much stuff has Nelly brought with her from Florida? I know. And it's just now arriving. A lot. She's unpacked nothing.
而且我们是在一条真正的公路上拍的。我是说，当然啦，对吧？我们总不能自己去修一条高速公路。这本来是显而易见的。我们以前也拍过。我们在拍潘和吉姆订婚戏时拍过，但这次没有。不，是在真正的路上。好了各位，我们要去“搬大件（haul some cube）”了。谢天谢地，我一直等着“搬大件”呢。我喜欢这个词组。我要开始用它了。我要去搬大件了。从今以后每次我搬家，我都要去搬大件。我要去搬大件。我喜欢这个词组。我要开始用它了。我要去搬大件了。我要去搬大件了。娜莉从佛罗里达带了多少东西过来？我知道。而且现在才刚到。好多。她什么都没拆包。
I just want to point out. I don't feel like she's ever going to unpack. I'm just going to say this. I think that Nelly just brings a bunch of boxes and one big comfy chair and that's it. She just digs in a box when she needs something. That's possible. Nelly's apartment was in a real apartment complex on Wilkerson Avenue in Valley Village. We did not build this set that we went on location for this. As Jim and Dwight helped Nelly, they're really struggling with one of her big oversized chairs. Dwight says, you know what? We'll work our magic, we'll make it fit.
我只想指出这一点。我觉得她永远都不会拆包了。我就这么说吧。我觉得娜莉只是带了一堆箱子和一把舒服的大椅子，没了。她只是在需要什么的时候才去箱子里翻。这倒有可能。娜莉的公寓在峡谷村（Valley Village）威尔克森大道（Wilkerson Avenue）上的一个真实公寓小区里。我们并没有为了外景搭建这个布景。当吉姆和德怀特帮娜莉搬家时，他们正费力地搬着她的一把超大号椅子。德怀特说，你知道吗？我们会发挥魔力，我们会把它塞进去的。
Nelly's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, let's not go there. Nothing is more repellent than magicians. Bunch of grown men, waving ones, pulling bunnies out of body crevices. Magicians are repulsive next topic. This is a lot of information out of nowhere. Super passionate amounts of information that don't really apply to moving you into your apartment.
娜莉却说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，别扯那个。没有什么比魔术师更让人反感的了。一群成年男人，挥舞着魔杖，从身体的各个缝隙里拉出兔子。魔术师太令人作呕了，下一个话题。这突然冒出大量的信息。一堆满腔热情的、与帮你搬家毫无关系的冗余信息。
Well, Jim's going to use that information. Pam's going to call him on the phone and tell him all about their hilarious bad party plan. And Jim says, oh, bad party plan. And Jim says, oh, hire a magician. Trust me. Mm-hmm. Well, we asked Steve Healey if they had been planting a seed about this magician's storyline
好吧，吉姆要利用这些信息了。潘会打电话给他，把他们那个滑稽的烂派对计划全都告诉他。吉姆说，哦，烂派对计划。吉姆说，哦，雇个魔术师吧。相信我。嗯哼。好吧，我们问过史蒂夫·希利，他们是不是早就为这个魔术师的故事线埋下了伏笔
with Nelly. Because remember in last week's episode when Nelly arrived in Scranton, she said she hated the Houdini Museum. I'm surprised she went. I don't think she went. I think she just knows it's there. Here's what Steve said. Steve said he doesn't really remember that they were intentionally
和奈莉一起。因为还记得上周的剧集里，当奈莉到达斯克兰顿的时候，她说她讨厌胡迪尼博物馆。我很惊讶她居然去了。我不觉得她去了。我觉得她只是知道那儿有这么个地方。史蒂夫是这么说的。史蒂夫说他其实不记得他们是有意
planning this whole magician's storyline. But he said there is some natural tension between comedians and magicians. Lots of comedy people start out as magicians are flirt with magic at some point. And comedians are also such skeptics they often get irrationally angry at magicians. And that might have been part of it. Steve said, I remember some of the writers in those days were going to the magic castle. Magic was a frequent topic in the room. I had no idea!
策划这整条魔术师的故事线的。但他说喜剧演员和魔术师之间确实存在某种天然的张力。很多喜剧圈的人一开始都是魔术师，或者在某个阶段对魔术很感兴趣。而且喜剧演员也都是坚定的怀疑论者，他们经常会对魔术师产生一种不理性的愤怒。这可能也是原因之一。史蒂夫说，我记得当年有些编剧会去魔术城堡。魔术是编剧室里经常讨论的话题。我完全不知道！
It's very funny. Isn't that? Well, remember I was a comedic magician. I performed my comedic magic show at Stand Up Knights. I still want to bring that back. I want to make it part of our live show. I want you to do your magic act. Of course! Why have I not been doing it?
太搞笑了。不是吗？好吧，记得我以前是个喜剧魔术师吗？我在“单口骑士”表演过我的喜剧魔术秀。我还是想把它弄回来。我想把它作为我们现场演出的一部分。我想让你来表演你的魔术。当然！我为什么一直没这么做呢？
I don't know. Done! Done! I still have the cassette tape of music, and I bought a, what do you call it? A tuxedo jacket with tails? With a vintage shop? I have it. I know the perfect moment in our live show. I love our live show.
我不知道。就这么定了！定啦！我还有那盘伴奏磁带，我还买了一件，叫什么来着？燕尾服夹克？在一家复古店买的？我留着呢。我知道在我们现场秀里的哪个时机用最完美。我爱我们的现场秀。
This has to happen, and I think I will be your assistant on roller skates. I am so disappointed we are only just now thinking of it, but I am so happy that we did. We have to add it. Andy and Aaron are going to arrive now at Jessica's family cabin. It is so charming. In the shooting draft, there was a scene where Aaron and Andy notice as they pull up, there seems to be a lot of people there. It read like this.
这绝对得安排上，而且我觉得我可以当你的轮滑助手。我太遗憾我们到现在才想到这个，但我又很高兴我们想到了。我们必须把它加进去。安迪和亚伦现在要到达杰西卡的家族木屋了。这里太迷人了。在拍摄剧本中，本来有一个场景是亚伦和安迪把车开过来时，注意到那里似乎有很多人。剧本是这样写的。
Exterior rural cabin. Andy and Aaron pull up to the cabin. There are several cars there. Andy says, why are there so many cars here? Aaron says Jessica's parents must be rich. But you know what, the cars aren't that nice. Personally, I'd rather have two really nice cars than seven crappy ones.
外景。乡村木屋。安迪和亚伦把车开到木屋旁。那里停了好几辆车。安迪说，为什么这里有这么多车？亚伦说杰西卡的父母一定很有钱。但你知道吗，那些车其实不怎么好。就我个人而言，我宁愿要两辆真正的好车，也不要七辆破车。
Guess that's why I'm not rich." Andy says, hmm, this is weird. And then there's a knock on their car window. Well, the knock on the window is from Lauren, played by Sue Redman. She studied acting at the Steppenwolf Theatre in Chicago and studied improv at Second City, Chicago. And according to IMDB, fun fact, she played a nurse in the movie Contagion and accidentally lodged a prop piece of medical equipment in Matt Damon's right ear. How do you do that? I don't know. She misused the prop equipment. I suppose I she's giving him an
我想这就是为什么我没有钱吧。安迪说，嗯，这太奇怪了。然后有人敲了他们的车窗。好吧，敲车窗的是劳伦，由苏·雷德曼饰演。她在芝加哥的荒原狼剧院学习过表演，并在芝加哥第二城剧团学习过即兴表演。根据IMDB的趣闻，她在电影《传染病》中饰演过一名护士，不小心把一件医疗道具卡在了马特·达蒙的右耳里。你怎么会做出这种事？我不知道。她错误使用了道具设备。我想她当时正在给他做
exam. And she lodged it in his ear. Yeah, I'm sure temporarily. Oh my God. You know what, this is exactly why I never, ever want to be on a medical show. I would do that. You might hurt somebody. I don't know. I just don't even know how you come back from that.
检查。结果卡在耳朵里了。天哪，我敢肯定是暂时的。哦天哪。你知道吗，这就是为什么我绝对、永远不想出演医疗剧。我会干出这种事。你可能会弄伤别人。我不知道。我只是甚至不知道那种情况下你怎么收场。
What is your end of the day, Convo like after a day like that? When you call your best friend. I don't know. You would not believe what I did to Matt Damon today. Yeah, that's how you would lead that combo. For sure. Well, Lauren's gonna tell them
经历那样的一天之后，你一结束一天的拍摄，收工后的对话是什么样的？当你给你的最好朋友打电话时。我不知道。你绝对不会相信我今天对马特·达蒙做了什么。对，你聊天时肯定会以此开头。肯定的。好吧，劳伦要告诉他们
that Jessica is not there. She's gone for a jog. This is right around the time when Erin and Andy realize that they've come upon a bachelor at party. She's wearing a veil in her hair. I would like to play a bullsh** card. What is it? Andy and Jessica are dating. They're in a full in her hair. I would like to play a bullsh** card. What is it?
杰西卡不在这里。她去慢跑了。这正值艾琳和安迪意识到他们闯入了一个单身派对的时候。她的头发上戴着面纱。我想出一张胡扯牌。是什么？安迪和杰西卡在约会。他们在头发里戴着面纱。我想出一张胡扯牌。是什么？
Andy and Jessica are dating. They're in a full-on relationship. Right. How is it that Andy wouldn't know that her good friend's getting married and they're gonna be having this bachelorette thing at the cabin? How?
安迪和杰西卡在约会。他们正在认真地谈恋爱。没错。安迪怎么会不知道她好朋友要结婚了，而且他们还要在木屋里搞这个单身派对呢？怎么会这样？
I hear you. You know, he knows she's at the cabin, but he doesn't know why. She's just there solo. Is he a bad listener? You know, did Jessica say, hey, this weekend I'm gonna be up at my parents' cabin. I'm hosting. I'm hosting.
我明白你的意思。你知道的，他知道她在木屋里，但他不知道原因。她只是独自一人在那儿。难道他是个糟糕的倾听者？你知道的，难道杰西卡没有说，嘿，这周末我要去我父母的木屋。我在主办。我在主办。
Yeah, I'm hosting the LaWripp party. It's kind of stressful. I have to buy extra groceries. Extra gummy penises. The gummy penises and a veil. And we have to have games. I'm gonna blow up a bunch of balloons. But people's names on them. Tape it to a poster board.
对，我在主办单身告别派对。这有点压力山大。我还得买额外的杂货。额外的软糖阴茎。软糖阴茎和面纱。我们还得玩游戏。我要吹一堆气球。把人们的名字写在上面。用胶带贴在展板上。
I'm very busy. I mean, that's how I communicate with Lee. He'd know all the deets. He'd know everything. We got a fan question from Santa M. in Houston, Texas, who said, where was Jessica's cabin actually located? It looks a lot like East Coast cabins. Well, I'll tell you, we shot this at a filming location called Canyon Ranch.
我太忙了。我的意思是，我跟李就是这样交流的。他会知道所有的细节。他什么都知道。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的粉丝圣·M.的一个问题，他说，杰西卡的木屋实际上位于哪里？它看起来很像东海岸的木屋。好吧，我来告诉你，我们是在一个叫峡谷牧场的拍摄地拍的。
It is in the Santa Monica Mountains. It's just a film location. They have tons of different cabins and houses and they have a fake gas station and a fake saloon. I looked all over the website. The cabin we used was fully decorated. If you go to the website, it looks exactly the same. This location has been used for all kinds of films and commercials. A lot of car commercials. I have a question for you. Yeah.
它位于圣莫尼卡山脉。它只是一个拍摄地。那里有大量不同的木屋和房子，还有一个假加油站和一个假小酒馆。我在他们的网站上到处找了个遍。我们用的那个木屋是完全装修好的。如果你去他们的网站看，它看起来一模一样。这个地方被用于各种电影和商业广告。很多汽车广告。我有个问题要问你。好的。
Has it been used for a horror movie? Because I always feel like places with lots of capins are where all the shit goes down. I am sure. But if you go to the website, they have a lot of rugged terrain. So you know the shot of people driving off-road to set up camp at a creek. Yeah. Canyon Ranch. Got it. Yeah. I saw a lot of those on the website. I didn't see any horror
它被用来拍过恐怖片吗？因为我总觉得有很多木屋的地方都是各种破事发生的地方。我敢肯定。但如果你去他们的网站看看，他们有很多崎岖的地形。所以你知道人们开车越野去小溪边扎营的那个镜头吗？对。峡谷牧场。懂了。对。我在网站上看到了很多那种地方。我没看到任何恐怖
movies, but I'm sure. Right. I wonder if Cabin in the Woods was shot there. We'll never know. I'll never know. I'm not detective. We'll never know. Well, Steve Healey said that the cabin they filmed at had some really kooky angles. Oh, yeah. And it was very challenging to get some of the shots. He also said that he didn't think the Santa Monica Mountains looked much like Pennsylvania, but our writer, Danny Chun,
电影，但我敢肯定。对。我在想《林中小屋》是不是在那里拍的。我们永远不会知道了。我永远不会知道了。我又不是侦探。我们永远不会知道了。好吧，史蒂夫·海利说他们拍摄的木屋有一些非常古怪的角度。哦，对。要拍到其中一些镜头非常有挑战性。他还说他觉得圣莫尼卡山脉看起来不太像宾夕法尼亚州，但我们的编剧丹尼·陈
is from that area and vouched for it. I thought it looked authentic. And the fact that the cabin came fully furnished probably means that we didn't move stuff around, which was challenging for us. Mm-hmm. I see that. Back to Nellie's apartment, Dwight is unpacking things, and he wonders out loud if King-Sai Sheets are called presidential in England, and he really wishes he had a Twitter account.
就是那个地区的人，他为此作了担保。我觉得它看起来很逼真。而且木屋自带全套家具，这可能意味着我们不需要搬动东西，这对我们来说很有挑战性。嗯哼。我明白。回到奈莉的公寓，德 Dwight 正在拆包裹，他大声琢磨英国把特大号床单叫不叫总统号床单，而且他真的很希望自己能有个推特账号。
Let me tell you what happened to me after this comment. Let me guess something to do with either bedding or Twitter. Bedding, okay. I wanted to know what our king size sheets called in England. What are they called? Well, the sheet sizes and bed sizes in England are called single double king king super king and emperor. Oh. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And none of them directly coordinate with American sizes.
让我告诉你在这条评论之后我身上发生了什么。让我猜猜，跟寝具或者推特有关。寝具，好吧。我想知道英国的特大号床单叫什么。它们叫什么？好吧，英国的床单尺寸和床的尺寸被称为单人、双人、国王、超级国王和皇帝。哦。嗯哼。对。而且它们没有一个能与美国的尺寸直接对应。
So if I bought a queen size bedding set and moved to the UK, it would not throw it in the trash. Throw it in the trash. Maybe cut it up, use it for rags. Well, it's not going gonna fit on your bed. What am I doing, cutting up bedshoes? If you rank the large beds by size, here's the order it would go in from smallest to largest. Okay. King, that's the smallest of the large beds.
所以如果我买了一套大号寝具搬到英国去，它根本——直接扔进垃圾桶。扔进垃圾桶。也许剪碎了当抹布用。好吧，它根本套不到你的床垫上。我干嘛要把床单剪碎？如果你按大小给大床排个序，从小到大顺序是这样的。好吧。国王，这是大床里最小的。
Okay. It goes king, super king, California king, Emperor. The two beds that are closest in size is the British, super king, and the American, California king. They're both 71 inches wide, but the California king is much longer. Yes.
好吧。顺序是国王、超级国王、加州国王、皇帝。尺寸最接近的两张床是英国的超级国王床和美国的加州国王床。它们的宽度都是71英寸，但加州国王床要长得多。对。
Then the super king. The Emperor bed is seven feet wide and seven feet long. It's humongous. Who's sleeping in that? Professional basketball players, I think. Not people, I guess. I googled it. The average professional basketball player is six six.
然后是超级国王床。皇帝床宽七英尺，长七英尺。它太庞大了。谁会睡在那上面？职业篮球运动员吧，我想。一般人不会吧，我猜。我谷歌了一下。职业篮球运动员的平均身高是六尺六寸。
So this Emperor Bed would be perfect for them. Yeah. I can't believe I know that. I mean, I really googled so much on this one, lady. Hey, get ready for your next cocktail party. You're going to be a delight. Guess what? There are more king beds than you could have ever imagined. In America, there is more than just the king and the California king. There is the Alaskan king, the Wyoming king, and the Texas king,
所以这个皇帝床对他们来说简直完美。对。真不敢相信我知道这些。我是说，这位女士，我真的在这上面谷歌了太多内容。嘿，准备好迎接你的下一个鸡尾酒会吧。你会成为全场的开心果。你猜怎么着？大床的种类比你想象的还要多。在美国，除了国王床和加州国王床，还有阿拉斯加国王床、怀俄明国王床和德克萨斯国王床，
and they're all bigger than the California King. The Wyoming King is the same as an emperor bed in the UK. The Alaskan King is the biggest bed. It is 9 feet by 9 feet. It runs anywhere from $3,500 to $10,000. I found a website called AlaskanKingBeds.com. They sell these beds, bed frames, and sheets, and bedding. In the photo, there is a family of six
它们都比加州国王床还要大。怀俄明国王床和英国的皇帝床是一样的。阿拉斯加国王床是最大的床。它的尺寸是9英尺乘9英尺。价格从3500美元到10000美元不等。我找到一个叫AlaskanKingBeds.com的网站。他们出售这些床、床架、床单和寝具。照片里有一个六口之家
and their full-size golden retriever dog all sitting on this bed with plenty of room to spare. It looks like a small swimming pool. It's so big. But what size of room is it in? That's the problem, right? Yeah. Big room, I guess.
和他们体型庞大的金毛寻回犬全都坐在张床上，空间还绰绰有余。它看起来就像一个小型游泳池。太大了。但它得放在多大的房间里才行？这才是问题所在，对吧？对。大房子吧，我猜。
I mean, I guess if I'm a professional basketball player, I got a sweet pad, and I need a lot of leg room. Yeah. I mean, remember those shows? Was it on MTV where it was like, you went and got to see people's houses? Was it called like, Cribbs or something? Yeah.
我的意思是，我想如果我是一个职业篮球运动员，我有一套豪华公寓，我确实需要很多腿部空间。对。我的意思是，还记得那些节目吗？是不是在MTV上那种你可以去参观别人房子的节目？是不是叫“Cribs”还是什么的？对。
I loved those. I saw Shaq Hyloneel's house. Maybe he had the Alaskan King. Did he have a big bed? He did. But it was like a giant circle bed. It was like a huge circle. Did your list include any big king-sized circle beds? Not specifically, that would be a custom bed, and it did say in the article that many NBA players have custom beds made for themselves to best fit their size.
我超喜欢那些。我看了沙奎尔·奥尼尔的房子。也许他就有阿拉斯加国王床。他有一张大床吗？有的。但那是一张巨大的圆床。那是一个巨大的圆。你的列表里有包含任何特大号的圆床吗？没有特别提到，那会是定制床，文章里确实说过很多NBA球员都会为自己定制床，以便最适合他们的体型。
Oh, well, Shaquille and Neil had one. And you know what, it had a giant Superman blanket on it. Oh. Yeah. In fact, this whole house had Superman stuff everywhere. Like the logo would be in the garage, on the shower doors, in the hedges. So yeah, he likes the theme. It was a nickname and he really leaned into it.
哦，好吧，沙奎尔·奥尼尔就有一张。而且你知道吗，上面还盖着一条巨大的超人毯子。哦。对。事实上，这整栋房子到处都是超人的东西。比如车库里、淋浴房门上、树篱里都有超人标志。所以，是的，他很喜欢这个主题。这是他的外号，而且他真的很沉迷其中。
Superman was one of his nicknames. Yes, kind of makes sense. It does make sense. It's a shotgun Superman. And maybe he flies with the ball. Yes, Angela, in the clutch, he flies with the ball. Oh, because he's clutch. He's the clutch.
超人是他的外号之一。是的，这有点说得通。确实说得通。是个速成超人。也许他带着球飞。对的，安吉拉，在关键时刻，他带着球飞。哦，因为他很关键。他是关键先生。
Yeah, he's of the team. He's the Superman clutch. He's lying with the ball. He's the SC of the clutch. Yeah, he's of the team. He's the Superman clutch. He's lying with the ball. He's the SC of the game. Oh, can you imagine us like being sports commentators? We would be so bad. I cannot. Oh gosh.
对，他是球队的……他是超人关键先生。他带着球飞。他是比赛的……哦，你能想象我们成为体育解说员吗？我们会解说得超级烂。我想象不出。哦天哪。
Anyway, okay, I'm so sorry, back to your king size beds. That's it. Okay. That's what I got. A lot of these very, very large beds are for family sleeps. People who like to co-sleep in one great big bed as a family. Okay.
不管怎样，好吧，太抱歉了，回到你的特大号床。就是这样。好吧。这就是我查到的。许多这种非常非常大的床都是为了全家人一起睡。喜欢全家人一起睡在一张超大床里的人。好吧。
And also your dog, I guess. Your giant dog. Your small Shetland pony. You could. A hundred percent put a small Shetland pony in this bed and still have room for your family of sex. Michael Scott could have slept at the foot of this bed and never even bothered Jan. A hundred percent this would have solved all their problems.
还有你的狗，我猜。你那巨大的狗。你那小型设德兰矮马。完全可以。百分之百可以把一只小型设德兰矮马放在这张床上，而且还能容纳你们六口之家。迈克尔·斯科特本来可以睡在这张床尾，甚至都不会打扰到简。百分之百，这能解决他们所有的问——
No bench needed. Jim and Dwight are now gonna find a shoebox that says do not open. So of course, what do they do? They open it. Dwight's going through all the pictures. Mm-hmm. I asked Steve Birch's, who is the man in the pictures? This was a background performer that they hired. He and Catherine had a big photo shoot on Monday morning of this week. It went from 7 to 9 a.m. and they changed their wardrobe.
根本不需要沙发凳。吉姆和德 Dwight 现在要找一个写着“请勿打开”的鞋盒。所以理所当然的，他们会怎么做？他们打开了。德 Dwight 正在翻看所有的照片。嗯哼。我问了史蒂夫·伯奇，照片里的男人是谁？这是他们雇的一个背景演员。他和凯瑟琳在本周一早上拍了一组大片。时间是从早上7点到9点，他们换了服装。
They take a picture, change clothes, take a picture. It's very, very tedious to do these prop photos like this. But that's what they did. They had a two-hour photo shoot to get all these pictures. Nelly is going to walk in and find them going through the shoe box and she says, oh, I see you found Benjamin. But Benjamin isn't the name of her ex-boyfriend. It's the name of the box that contains pictures of Henry. That's right. Her ex-boyfriend. box that contains pictures of Henry. That's right, her ex-boyfriend. And this is when she's going to share with them all about this tragic breakup. Yeah. She had to sell their home at a loss. Yeah. And then there's a photo of Nelly and Henry and he's got a, looks like a magician's cape and they're like, is this for Halloween? And she goes, no, that's the worst of it. He's the magician.
拍一张照片，换一身衣服，再拍一张。拍这种道具照片非常非常繁琐。但他们就是这么做的。他们进行了两个小时的写真拍摄来拍完所有这些照片。奈莉走进来发现他们在翻那个鞋盒，她说，哦，我看到你们找到本杰明了。但本杰明不是她前男友的名字。那是装着亨利照片的盒子的名字。没错。她的前男友。装着亨利照片的盒子的名字。没错，她的前男友。正是在这个时候，她要跟他们分享这段悲惨的分手经历。对。她不得不亏本卖掉他们的房子。对。然后有一张奈莉和亨利的合影，他戴着一顶——看起来像魔术师的斗篷，然后他们就问，这是万圣节拍的吗？结果她说，不，这才是最糟的。他是个魔术师。
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da- she cried, she said, please don't tell anyone back at work about this. It was a vulnerable moment. So Jim tries to call Pam, tells her to call off the pranks, cancel the magician at least. Yes. So in the shooting draft, the main girls in the break room scene actually was mid-process. They were still trading horrible ideas and Pam leaves to take the phone call and comes back. But there was a whole added beat where they're still trading ideas and Pam leaves to take the phone call and comes back. But there was a whole added beat where they're still trading ideas before Pam gets the phone call. And Angela actually gets very tickled and she gets the giggles.
她哭了，她说，请不要把这件事告诉公司里的任何人。这是一个脆弱的时刻。所以吉姆试图打电话给潘，让她取消恶作剧，至少取消那个魔术师。是的。所以，在拍摄剧本中，茶水间里主要女演员们的戏份其实是在进行到一半时。她们当时还在互相交换各种可怕的主意，然后潘起身去接电话又回来了。但其实还有一个整段加戏，在潘接到电话之前，她们还在互相出谋划策。而且安吉拉实际上被逗得咯咯直笑。
In the shooting draft it says Angela giggles into her hands. It's indelated scenes if you guys are curious what it sounds like when Angela Martin gets the giggles. Let's hear it. I got one. Let's pretend that we thought it was her birthday and get her a cake with a few too many candles on it. Like 49.
拍摄剧本里写着：安吉拉捂着嘴咯咯直笑。如果你们好奇安吉拉·马丁咯咯笑起来是什么声音，这在删减片段里有。我们听听看。我有一个。假装我们以为今天是她的生日，给她买个蜡烛多得有点过分的蛋糕。比如49根。
Pam! That is brilliant! Well this is new. So this one are we a gaysha? What the? Wow. Wow! I mean, I remember doing that. So, what are we at Gaysha? What the? Wow. Wow.
潘！这太棒了！好吧，这倒是新鲜。所以这个，我们扮的是艺伎吗？什么鬼？哇。哇！我的记得我当时演过那个。所以，我们扮的是艺伎吗？什么鬼？哇。哇！
I mean, I remember doing that. I remember brainstorming with Ed and Steve about what does it look like when Angela's this tickled. So, they had me cover my face with my hands almost kind of like what Mindy does when she gets tickled. When she actually laughs. When she actually laughs and is trying not to break on camera. And then they just said, Angela, just like a high-pitched kind of giggle over and over. So I did. I was just like, and anyway, it was cracking us up. It was kind of like the moment when we learned Angela eats like a squirrel. You know, lady when Pam does come back in the
我的记得我当时演过那个。我还记得跟埃德和史蒂夫一起头脑风暴，讨论安吉拉被逗得这么开心时会是什么样子。所以，他们让我用双手捂住脸，有点像明迪被逗乐时的那种感觉。当她真的笑出来的时候。当她真的笑出来，并且极力忍住不笑场的时候。然后他们就说，安吉拉，就用那种高音调的咯咯笑声一遍又一遍地笑。于是我就照做了。我就像……总之，这把我们都逗得哈哈大笑。这有点像我们发现安吉拉吃东西像松鼠的那一刻。你知道吗，女士，当潘回来的时候……
break room after her phone call with Jim at 11 minutes and 22 seconds, I am now wearing my Pam engagement ring and wedding band. They're back on. Someone caught it. Someone found it. Pam is gonna try to get them to call off this prank party and no one is having it. Yeah. Yeah. Toots, we're not stopping this train, so get off the tracks, Phyllis says.
茶水间里，就在她和吉姆在11分22秒通完电话之后，我现在戴上了我的帕姆订婚戒指和结婚戒指。它们又戴回去了。有人注意到了。有人发现了。帕姆打算让他们取消这个恶作剧派对，但根本没人理她。是啊。是啊。菲莉丝说，得了吧，我们可不会停下这列火车，所以快从铁轨上下来吧。
That's right. In the shooting draft, one of the things that Pam tells Jim is you need to stall. Like, if she's going to like rearrange this party, he's got to stall. And this scene made it into deleted scenes, Jim trying to stall. And we learned some new things about Nelly.
没错。在拍摄剧本中，帕姆对吉姆说的话之一就是你需要拖延时间。比如说，如果她要重新安排这个派对，他就得拖延时间。这个场景最后被收录进了删减片段中，吉姆在努力拖延时间。我们还了解到了关于内莉的一些新情况。
I thought you might like to hear it. All right, then. Let's get going. All right oh you know what though house really isn't a home until we've made some memories here some conversations. So let's sit back down and let's mix them. No we've got work to do back at work. Okay well I think British Idol is worse than American Idol. Thoughts? I would know I don't go for all that cheesy reality stuff. Okay. More of a survivor fan. Right. Well, I think that cricket is a stupid version of baseball.
我想你可能会喜欢听这个。好吧，那就这样。我们开始吧。好吧，哦，你知道吗，其实一个房子只有在这里留下一些回忆和对话，才真正算是一个家。所以让我们坐下来，把它们融合在一起。不，我们在工作上还有工作要做。好吧，我觉得英国偶像比美国偶像更烂。大家怎么看？我可不知道，我对那些俗气的真人秀不感兴趣。好吧。我更喜欢《幸存者》。好吧。我觉得板球是棒球的愚蠢版本。
Woo! Everything is a stupid version of something. A bike is a stupid car. A baby is a stupid adult. Come back to the office. I've got a list. Nelly's stupid. Would you mind giving me a piggyback on the way down?
哇！万物皆是某事物的愚蠢版本。自行车是愚蠢的汽车。婴儿是愚蠢的成年人。快回办公室。我有个名单。内莉太蠢了。你介意在下楼的路上背我一下吗？
Piggieback. Piggieback is a stupid version of the fireman's carry. Hello. I think British food is gross. That was delightful. Uh-huh. I loved every minute of that. Nellie is a survivor fan. She also has a list of stupid and I asked if he really I was like, please tell me you guys pitched Nellie's list of stupids. He said, I'm sure we did. He said, I couldn't find it. But she has a lot on her list. I have to imagine that Nellie's list of
背。背是乌鸦背人（消防员抱）的愚蠢版本。你好。我觉得英国食物很恶心。太棒了。嗯哼。我喜欢其中的每一分钟。内莉是《幸存者》的粉丝。她还有一个蠢货名单，我问他是不是真的，我说，求求你们告诉我，你们向内莉提出了蠢货名单这个主意吧。他说，我确信我们做过。他说，我找不到了。但她的名单上有很多东西。我不得不想象内莉的
stupids took up like a good two hours of one of their evenings. I feel like they just would have loved pitching on that. We are back at the cabin. The bachelor party is playing a game. And rather than Andy asking Jessica to step outside with him while he has a private conversation with him, they have instead decided to join the Bachelor at Party. Again, they're meant to be together. I've done a 180. Because
蠢货名单花掉了他们某天晚上整整两个小时的时间。我觉得他们一定会很喜欢想出这些点子。我们回到了木屋。单身汉派对正在玩游戏。安迪没有让杰西卡和他一起走到外面去进行私下对话，而是决定加入单身汉派对。真的，他们天生就该在一起。我已经彻底改变看法了。因为
the two of them together make horrible choices. I know. This is why the balance with Jessica was so important, or whatever, we've said it so much. We're gonna let it go. Let's also point out that the Bachelorette's have been day drinking and this party is amping up. They're popping balloons of all the X's
他们两个在一起会做出可怕的选择。我知道。这就是为什么与杰西卡的平衡如此重要，或者随便怎么说吧，我们已经说得够多了。我们不提了。我们还要指出的是，单身女郎们一直在白天喝酒，这个派对正在变得越来越嗨。她们正在戳破所有前任的气球
that have done her wrong and making speeches. First balloon to go is John. I also saw Matthew Greg, Mike, and some other name that started with the C. They're really going to get into it. Aaron's getting anxious. She's like, I don't know about all this. And he's like, hey, it's going to be fine. Just act natural. Do you want a gummy penis? And she said, no, there's also like a bowl of gummy bears. And Andy goes these are delicious and Aaron goes but their penises. Mm-hmm. Lord help me I googled gummy penises.
那些对不起她的人，并发表演讲。第一个破掉的气球是约翰的。我还看到了马修、格雷格、迈克，以及其他以C开头的名字。她们真的要大干一场了。亚伦开始感到焦虑。她觉得，我不知道这一切是怎么回事。而他说，嘿，会没事的。只要表现得自然点。你想来个软糖丁丁吗？她说，不，这里还有一碗小熊软糖。安迪说这些太好吃了，亚伦说但它们是丁丁形状的。嗯哼。上帝救救我，我谷歌搜索了软糖丁丁。
These are a mainstay of Bachelorette parties. I've never seen one. What? Sam? Cassie have you seen a gummy penis? Oh yeah, of course. I haven't. Okay, it's like, what's Sam?
这些是单身派对的中流砥柱。我从来没见过。什么？萨姆？卡西，你见过软糖丁丁吗？哦，是的，当然。我没见过。好吧，这就像，萨姆是什么？
And John are like duh, of course. Yeah,'t. Okay, it's like, for Sam and Jen are like, duh. Of course. They're with penis straws and all the bachelor's. You haven't seen like the gummy penis straws. I've seen a penis straw. I've never seen a gummy penis. But guess what? You can buy him on Amazon.
而约翰的反应是，废话，当然。是的，没见过。好吧，这就像，对于萨姆和詹来说，废话。当然。它们伴随着丁丁吸管和所有的单身汉。你没见过那种软糖丁丁吸管吗？我见过丁丁吸管。我从来没见过软糖丁丁。但你猜怎么着？你可以在亚马逊上买到。
The ones I found are called jelly willies. But oh man, guys, there's so much. There's penis-shaped chocolates. Lots of lollipops cakes I wondered if any of these items were sold at the penis museum in Iceland are they? It does have a gift shop. I couldn't see what all was at the gift shop But the penis museum has a cafe and they serve Oreo coconut penis waffles and they have a seasonal Christmas penis waffle What's that? It's a waffle shaped like a penis.
我找到的那些叫做果冻威利。但是哦天哪，伙计们，还有太多了。有丁丁形状的巧克力。各种棒棒糖、蛋糕，我甚至在想这些东西里有没有人在冰岛的丁丁博物馆卖过，真的有吗？它确实有一个礼品店。我看不清礼品店里到底有什么，但丁丁博物馆里有一家咖啡馆，他们供应奥利奥椰子丁丁华夫饼，他们还有季节性的圣诞丁丁华夫饼。那是什么？那是一个做成丁丁形状的华夫饼。
But it's seasonal, so is it like pumpkin spiced? Or Christmas spiced? Yeah, what's the season? It looks like it has strawberries and whipped cream. That doesn't scream Christmas to me. Well, listen, I'm not gonna argue with the people in Iceland about their penis waffles.
但它是季节性的，所以它就像南瓜香料味的吗？还是圣诞香料味的？是的，什么季节？它看起来像是加了草莓和鲜奶油。这可一点也不让我觉得有圣诞节的感觉。好吧，听着，我可不会跟冰岛人争论他们的丁丁华夫饼。
You're not? No. I'm gonna call someone up. I'm gonna let them have it. Really berate them about it. Oreo coconut penis waffle. Sounds'm gonna let them have it. Really berate them about it. Oreo coconut, penis waffle. Sounds delicious. A lot going on.
你不会吗？不会。我要打电话给某人。我要把他们痛骂一顿。狠狠地斥责他们一番。奥利奥椰子丁丁华夫饼。听起来我要把他们痛骂一顿。狠狠地斥责他们一番。奥利奥椰子丁丁华夫饼。听起来很好吃。事情真多。
I love how surprised you are by all of the penis there's a whole industry of penis desserts. Yeah, out there. Maybe there's some savory penis stuff. I didn't see any penis crackers. Someone get on it. Penis potato chips, they're probably out there. I don't know. I only found desserts. I don't know why that's so funny to me. There's a whole untapped market.
我喜欢你对所有丁丁感到惊讶的样子，这里有一个完整的丁丁甜点产业。是的，外面确实有。也许还有一些咸味的丁丁制品。我没看到任何丁丁饼干。谁来做点这个吧。丁丁薯片，外面可能也有。我不知道。我只找到了甜点。我不知道为什么这对我来说这么搞笑。这是一个完全未被开发的市场。
Yes, that's what you're saying. Something get on it. At this point, Megan, who was played by Dana Powell, you might recognize her from Bridesmaids or the good place or modern family, she's going to come up to Andy and just give them a bunch of big bear hugs and say, you know, he's nothing like these awful X's and she wants him to sing. She wants him to sing for everybody. Dana is hilarious. And the shooting draft, it said her name was Megan R. There were two maigants, I guess. And she was the quote, drunken rugby girl. Dana and I have known each other a long time. She you have. Yeah, yeah. We did improv at iOS together. She's someone that just is instantly
是的，这就是你想说的。谁来搞定这个。此时，由达娜·鲍威尔饰演的梅根——你可能在《伴娘》、《善地》或《摩登家庭》中认出她——她会走向安迪，给他几个熊抱，然后说，你知道的，他跟那些糟糕的前任一点也不一样，她想让他唱歌。她想让他为所有人唱歌。达娜太搞笑了。在拍摄剧本中，她的名字叫梅根·R。我想有两个梅根。她被称为“喝醉的橄榄球女孩”。我和达娜认识很久了。你们确实认识。对，对。我们在IO一起做过即兴表演。她是一个那种能立刻
hilarious, like makes really strong choices right away and is so freaking funny. She was great in this episode. I know. I love everything she did. I know. We had a fan question from Rose T. and Canada, who said, when Andy starts to sing a song, I'm not sure if you're familiar with the song, but it's called Lock Lomond, and it's an old Scottish folk song. The story is sorrowful, but the song is so beautiful and full of hope. It makes me feel that I'll always be able to find a way home, and it reminds me of my Scottish ancestry and the land that my ancestors were forced to leave behind. I highly recommend listening to the whole song.
搞笑的人，比如一上来就能做出非常强烈的选择，而且超级搞笑。她在这一集里演得太棒了。我知道。我喜欢她做的一切。我知道。我们有一个来自加拿大罗斯T.的粉丝提问，她说，当安迪开始唱一首歌时，我不确定你是否熟悉这首歌，但它叫《洛蒙德湖》，是一首古老的苏格兰民歌。这个故事很悲伤，但歌曲非常优美，充满希望。它让我觉得我总能找到回家的路，它让我想起了我的苏格兰血统和我的祖先被迫离开的土地。我强烈推荐完整听一下这首歌。
Do you know who chose that song for Andy to start singing? Was it Ed or one of the writers? Well Rose, that was scripted. And I did take your advice and I went and listened to the whole song and I have a little audio clip for us because it is really truly beautiful You thought you weren't gonna hear more music today, but you are. This is our music episode. I am so excited because Rose I have been to Lock Lomond. Hey, I have stayed at Lock Lomond. I've been on a boat on Lock Lomond. It's beautiful. I want to hear the song I want to hear the song. Love will never meet again On the bunny-bunny bane Star-flag-loom-man
你知道是谁选了这首歌让安迪唱的吗？是埃德还是某个编剧？嗯，罗斯，那是剧本里写好的。我确实采纳了你的建议，去听了整首歌，我为我们准备了一个小音频剪辑，因为它真的是太美了。你以为今天听不到更多音乐了，但你还是会听到。这是我们的音乐特辑。我太兴奋了，因为罗斯，我去过洛蒙德湖。嘿，我在洛蒙德湖住过。我坐过洛蒙德湖上的船。那里太美了。我想听这首歌，我想听这首歌。爱将永远不会再相见 在邦尼-邦尼贝恩 斯特星-旗-织机-人
Oh, you take the high road And I'll take the low road And I'll be in Scotland land of foe, but me and my true love will never meet again on the bunny-bony bane of Locke Loma. Isn't that beautiful? It is beautiful. That was Peter Hollins.
哦，你走阳关道 而我走独木桥 我将身处充满敌意的苏格兰土地，但我和我的真爱将永远不会在洛蒙德湖的邦尼-邦尼贝恩再次相遇。这不是很美吗？真的很美。那是彼得·霍林斯。
Well, I loved it, and Lock Loman is gorgeous. I will share a picture. In our stories. Yes, that are now highlighted. Rose, thank you so much for writing in about that. Well, the Mean Girls Party is about to start. Pam's like, listen, if you're going to be mean, just try to be subtle. Darryl suggests they have a code name for Nellie.
嗯，我很喜欢，洛蒙德湖太美了。我会分享一张照片。在我们的快拍里。是的，现在已经置顶了。罗斯，非常感谢你写信来谈这个。好了，刻薄女孩派对要开始了。帕姆说，听着，如果你要刻薄，尽量委婉一点。达里尔建议他们给内莉起个代号。
I have two favorite lines from this episode, and the first one is in this couple of dialogue. Okay. Daryl says, in the warehouse, we use code names for people we want to talk about. Andy was jelly roll, Mike was Dennis the Menace, Ryan was douchebag. Ryan says, hey, that's not a code name, that's just an insult.
我有两句这集里最喜欢的台词，第一句就在这段对话里。好吧。达里尔说，在仓库里，我们用代号来称呼我们想谈论的人。安迪是果冻卷，迈克是恶魔丹尼斯，瑞安是混蛋。瑞安说，嘿，那不是代号，那只是侮辱。
And here's my favorite line, Oscar says, plus everyone would know who you met. And here's my favorite line, Oscar says, plus everyone would know who you meant. And then Ryan goes, yeah, I know. It made me laugh. It was so perfect. The code name Pam pitches is Mondays. Everyone is annoyed with Mondays, right? Ryan, who I think still really doesn't like Pam, says, no, let's use the codename Pam and everyone agrees. I don't know if you notice, but at 13 minutes and 37 seconds, the top of Angela's ponytail is a mess. There's hairs going everywhere. That's because in the shooting draft, there was a scene where Meredith comes into the break room and is delighted by what she sees.
这是我最喜欢的台词，奥斯卡说，而且每个人都会知道你指的是谁。这是我最喜欢的台词，奥斯卡说，而且每个人都会知道你指的是谁。然后瑞安说，对，我知道。这把我逗笑了。太完美了。帕姆提出的代号是“星期一”。每个人都讨厌星期一，对吧？瑞安——我觉得他可能还是很讨厌帕姆——说，不，我们用代号“帕姆”吧，大家都同意了。我不知道你们有没有注意到，在13分37秒时，安吉拉的马尾辫顶部一团糟。到处都是头发。那是因为在拍摄剧本中，有一个场景是梅瑞狄斯走进茶水间，对她看到的情景感到高兴。
She turns to Angela and says, the break room, what kind of crap party is this? Angela smiles mischievously at Meredith. Meredith puts her in a headlock, says, oh, was this you kiddo? And gives her a nugie. Oh! And then Angela shoves Meredith away. And that's why her hair's a mess.
她转向安吉拉说，茶水间，这算什么烂派对？安吉拉淘气地向梅瑞狄斯笑。梅瑞狄斯把她锁喉，说，哦，这是你吗，小家伙？还给了她一个栗暴。哦！然后安吉拉把梅瑞狄斯推开。这就是为什么她的头发一团糟。
Very interesting. Well, Nelly's going to and they're gonna start with Creed serenading her. Mm-hmm. He says, get comfy. This first song is over 30 minutes long. Oh my gosh, lady. I remember us cracking up.
非常有意思。好吧，内莉要去了，他们将从克里德对她的深情献唱开始。嗯哼。他说，坐舒服点。这首歌第一首有30多分钟长。哦天哪，天哪。我记得我们笑得前仰后合。
I know. There was a candy bag alt for this. Okay. And it's so funny. Creed would have, instead of saying the song is 30 minutes long, he would have said, the first song is audience participation. When I say go, you all start moaning like you're dying or something. Wow. Can you imagine? I have a fun fact about the guitar that Creed is playing.
我知道。这里有一个糖果袋的替代版本。好吧。而且太搞笑了。克里德本可以说这首歌有30分钟长，但他却说，这首歌的第一首是观众参与环节。当我喊开始时，你们所有人都要开始呻吟，就像你们快死了一样。哇。你能想象吗？关于克里德弹的那把吉他，我有一个有趣的冷知识。
Is it his actual guitar? It's his personal guitar. It's a limited edition replica of Robert Johnson's 1926 Gibson L1. Robert Johnson was an American blues musician and songwriter. If you go to Creed's house, he has a wall of guitars and mandalins and a banjo and the man like Ed, he can just pick up anything with strings pretty much and play it. Yeah. We're going back to the cabin again now, and Aaron tells Andy, I think we should leave. But Andy says, I'm gonna get this breakup over with. He pulls Jessica aside finally. He's babbling and she says, wait a second,
那是他真正的吉他吗？那是他个人的吉他。那是罗伯特·约翰逊1926年吉布森L1的限量版复刻品。罗伯特·约翰逊是一位美国蓝调音乐家和词曲作者。如果你去克里德家，他有一整面墙的吉他、曼陀林和一把班卓琴，而且这个人就像埃德一样，他几乎可以拿起任何有弦的乐器就弹起来。是的。我们现在又要回到木屋了，亚伦对安迪说，我想我们应该离开。但安迪说，我要把这场分手做个了断。他终于把杰西卡拉到一边。他语无伦次，而她说，等一下，
are you dumping me? Are you dumping me for Aaron? You said she wasn't relationship material and she wasn't as good as me. Jessica, this is not you, Jessica. Jessica, you're doing a low blow here, lady. Not cool. I had a turn here, not cool.
你在甩我吗？你要为了亚伦甩我吗？你说过她不是谈恋爱的那块料，她没有我优秀。杰西卡，这不是你，杰西卡。杰西卡，你现在有点人身攻击了，小姐。太不地道了。我在这里反转一下，太不地道了。
What Andy and Erin are doing is not cool, but that was not cool. But at the same time, she's pissed off, lady. Who knows what you would have said? True. You might have, like, listen. I'm not cool. But at the same time she's pissed off lady. Who knows what you would have said. True. You might have like, listen. I'm not Jessica. I know. I know Jessica is better than this comment. We have put Jessica on a pedestal. But I do think lots of us, maybe in that moment, would have been like, are you f***ing kidding me right now? Mm-hmm. I think that would have been better than these low blows to Erin in this moment.
安迪和亚伦的做法很不地道，但刚才那个也不地道。但与此同时，她气炸了，小姐。谁知道你会说出什么话来？确实。你可能会说，听着。我很不地道。但与此同时她气炸了，小姐。谁知道你会说出什么话来。确实。你可能会说，听着。我不是杰西卡。我知道。我知道杰西卡比这句评论更好。我们把杰西卡放在了神坛上。但我确实认为我们中的很多人，也许在那一刻，会觉得，你现在是在跟我开什么国际玩笑吗？嗯哼。我觉得这总比此刻对亚伦进行人身攻击要好。
And he starts to panic. He's like, blah, blah, blah, blah, no, no, no, wait, wait, okay, you want honesty, super honesty time? I'm gay. Mm-hmm. And Jessica's like, what? Yeah, her gay friend Kenny claims to have known this all along. He's like, I knew it.
安迪开始惊慌失措。他语无伦次地说，不，不，不，等等，等等，好吧，你想听实话，超级诚实的时间？我是同性恋。嗯哼。杰西卡一脸茫然：什么？是的，她那个同性恋朋友肯尼声称自己早就知道了。他说，我早就知道了。
Jessica says, Andy, you're not gay. I mean, when we were together, you seemed pretty excitable. And he's like, well, I was faking it. I had to fake it every time. Yeah, he imagined he was in a steam room with John Stamos. Jessica then says, I can't say it doesn't make sense. And then she says, look, you know what, Andy, it's fine.
杰西卡说，安迪，你不是同性恋。我的意思是，当我们在交往的时候，你看起来挺容易激动的。而他说，嗯，我是装的。我每次都得装。是的，他想象自己和约翰·斯塔莫斯在一个蒸汽浴室里。杰西卡接着说，我不能说这毫无道理。然后她说，听着，你知道吗，安迪，没关系。
I didn't think we were gonna get married or anything. I'm just, I'm just upset for now. There's the Jessica we know. Yeah, there's fine. I didn't think we were gonna get married or anything. I'm just upset for now. There's the Jessica. We know. There's the Jessica we know. I wanna give a shout out to Kenny who was played by Greg Worswick. He was a main company member
我本来也没想过我们要结婚什么的。我只是，我只是现在觉得很不高兴。这就是我们认识的杰西卡。是的，没关系。我本没想过我们要结婚什么的。我只是现在觉得很不高兴。这就是杰西卡。我们认识的杰西卡。这就是我们认识的杰西卡。我要向由格雷戈·沃斯威克饰演的肯尼致敬。他是洛杉矶格朗德剧团的
at the Groundlings in Los Angeles. He's been in Bridesmaids, Curbian Thusiasum, Superstore, Parks and Rec, and crossover connection with you and Brett Gellman, fresh off the boat. Hey! Is fresh off the boat, and crossover connection with you and Brett Gellman fresh off the boat. Hey, is fresh off the boat our new crossover connection? Maybe. Sorry, Monk. Might be. Well, Andy and Erin are now really awkwardly going to leave the cabin. You can tell Erin,
核心成员。他出演过《伴娘》、《消烦》、《超级超市》、《公园与游憩》，还有你和布雷特·杰尔曼合作的跨界剧集《初来乍到》。嘿！《初来乍到》是我们的新跨界剧集吗？也许吧。抱歉，蒙克。可能是吧。好吧，安迪和亚伦现在非常尴尬地离开木屋。你能看出亚伦，
you know, those comments stung. Yeah. And now she's wondering what all Andy said about her. She's going to kind of just start to shut down. Mm-hmm. She's going to take a nap. Well, she saw a lot of turkeys and it made her tired. Yeah. Andy's picking up on these cues. He really didn't handle that well. And now he hasn't set himself up to succeed with Aaron.
你知道的，那些评论刺痛了她。是的。现在她开始琢磨安迪到底都说了她些什么。她差不多开始自我封闭了。嗯哼。她打算小睡一会儿。好吧，她看到了很多火鸡，这让她觉得累了。是的。安迪注意到了这些信号。他那件事确实处理得不够好。现在他在亚伦面前没有为成功做好铺垫。
And he wants to do right by it. At least right by Aaron, not so much right by Jessica, so he turns back around. He goes back to the cabin. And he wants to tell Jessica the truth, and here it is. He's in love with Aaron. She's totally relationship material. Aaron is so happy. She is beaming.
他想弥补过失。至少对亚伦做正确的事，对杰西卡就没那么讲究了，所以他转过身去。他又回到了木屋。他想对杰西卡说实话，就是这样。他爱上了亚伦。她完全是谈恋爱的好材料。亚伦太开心了。她笑逐颜开。
Jessica and her friends literally yell and chase them to the car, throwing, it looks like wedding cake at them. And they peel out and drive away and they're so happy. Yeah, and they finally kiss. Yeah, yeah. Jessica's friends are gonna talk about Andy for a long time. I feel like on her gummy penis weekend,
杰西卡和她的朋友们简直在大喊大叫并追着他们到车前，向他们扔着看起来像是婚礼蛋糕的东西。然后他们猛踩油门开车离开，他们太开心了。是的，他们终于接吻了。是的，是的。杰西卡的朋们会讨论安迪很长时间。我觉得在她那个软糖丁丁周末，
Bachelorette party, there's gonna be a big balloon labeled Andy. They sure is. Up next is maybe one of my favorite scenes. We filmed for the whole season. This, I mean, we laughed so hard. Okay, so here's what's going on. We're back in the mean girls in the break room party.
单身派对上，会有一个贴着“安迪”标签的大气球。他们肯定会的。接下来也许是我最喜欢的场景之一。我们为整整一季拍摄了这个。这个，我是说我们笑得太厉害了。好吧，事情是这样的。我们回到了刻薄女孩茶水间派对。
And everyone is giving a toast, but the toast are really mean-spirited towards Pam. Quote on Quote Pam. And it ends with everyone chanting, we hate Pam. Mm-hmm. And that's when our magician enters. Yeah. He offers to make Pam disappear.
每个人都在敬酒，但这些祝酒对帕姆来说真的很刻薄。所谓的帕姆。最后以大家齐声高喊“我们讨厌帕姆”结束。嗯哼。就在这时，我们的魔术师登场了。是的。他主动提出让帕姆消失。
Poof. Yeah. Where do we even start with the scene? I don't know. John Krizinski had to stand right next to Brett Galman, and this was a mistake. Mistake. This was a noodle moment for John.
砰。是的。我们究竟该从这个场景的哪里开始呢？我不知道。约翰·卡拉辛斯基不得不紧挨着布雷特·杰尔曼站着，这是一个错误。错误。这对约翰来说是个面条时刻。
A full noodle. He couldn't even stand. I scoured the season eight bloopers hoping that they would be in there and they are not. They are somewhere. Dave Rogers has got to have them. I was so thankful that I was off camera. I will. First of all, wait, before we get ahead of ourselves. Did you
彻底的面条时刻。他甚至站都站不稳。我搜遍了第八季的失误集锦，希望能看到它们在里面，但并没有。它们肯定在某个地方。戴夫·罗杰斯一定有。我很庆幸自己当时不在镜头前。我会的。首先，等等，在我们自作聪明之前。你知道
know in the shooting draft this character's name was called Magic Mark. I didn't. Okay so the scene was extended and he would have had this introduction moment where he came in the room. It read like this. Okay everyone so my name is Magic Mark. I used to be a Magic Marker and then he holds up a magic marker. And then he says, but then I got rid of, he produces a DVD of E-R and says, the E-R, magic! And he made it disappear. Oh!
在拍摄剧本中，这个角色的名字叫魔术师马克吗？我不知道。好吧，这个场景被延长了，他本该有一个他走进房间的自我介绍环节。内容是这样的。好了，各位，我叫魔术师马克。我以前是一支马克笔，然后他举起一支马克笔。接着他说，但是后来我摆出，他拿出一张《急诊室的故事》的DVD，说，急诊室，太神奇了！然后他让它消失了。哦！
And it says that Jim Clarksnelly, who has a very tight smile, she's not a fan of magic mark. Here's the amazing thing about this, which is that we did not hire a magician. Instead, Brett Gilman had to kind of learn some of this slight of hand on the fly, like the little exploding fire thing in the hand. Steve Burgess says that's actually a really easy one. But when you see him in the episode when he brings the dove, the bird,
剧本上说吉姆看着内莉，内莉脸上带着非常勉强的微笑，她不是魔术师马克的粉丝。这里神奇的地方在于，我们并没有真的雇佣一个魔术师。相反，布雷特·吉尔曼不得不临场学一些这种手法，比如手里那个会爆炸的小火球。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这其实是一个非常简单的把戏。但当你在剧集里看到他变出鸽子、那只鸟的时候，
it was so awkward and clumsy every time. It was so, it was never good. And we couldn't get through that moment. Look what I wrote, what? We could not get through this moment. No, every time that bird appeared. It was so ridiculous. And it was so close to John to you.
每一次都显得那么尴尬和笨拙。太尴尬了，从来没好过。我们根本无法顺利拍完那一幕。看看我写了什么，什么？我们根本无法顺利通过这一幕。不，每次那只鸟出现的时候。太荒谬了。而且离约翰离你那么近。
Oh my God. Well, magic mark is going to ask Nelly if she would like to be his special volunteer for the day, but Jim is gonna step in and he's gonna start sabotaging the act. Yeah. And then Pam is also gonna get in on this sabotage. My second favorite line of the whole episode
哦天哪。好吧，魔术师马克要问内莉是否愿意成为他今天的特别志愿者，但吉姆要插手并开始破坏他的表演。是的。然后帕姆也要加入进来进行破坏。整集里我第二喜欢的台词
is when Robert turns to Dwight and says, why is Jim treating the magician poorly? Yeah. There's also a moment when Brett as the magician looks at Jim and goes, what the hell, man? I'm gonna clean show. This was the second thing that we couldn't get through because it's just this like burst
就是罗伯特转向德怀特说，为什么吉姆对魔术师态度不好？是的。还有一个时刻是布雷特作为魔术师看着吉姆说，搞什么鬼，老兄？我要好好表演。这是第二件我们无法顺利拍完的事情，因为这就像是一种突然爆发的
of anger. He's been holding it together the whole time. We also lost it when he singled out Phyllis. Yes. When he said, all right, where's Phyllis? Who's Phyllis? Look, this is really uncool, okay? You can see Phyllis laughing.
愤怒。他一直在强忍着。当他单独挑出菲莉丝时，我们也彻底笑崩了。是的。当他说，好吧，菲莉丝在哪里？谁是菲莉丝？听着，这真的很不酷，好吗？你能看到菲莉丝在笑。
You can see her laughing. Yeah. And then Dwight says, scram wizard. And then they argue all the way out the door down the hallway, that was not scripted. Oh, amazing. They were just, you was just supposed to get them out of the room,
你能看到她在笑。是的。然后德怀特说，快滚开，巫师。然后他们一路争吵着走出门，顺着走廊离开，那根本不是剧本里写的。哦，太棒了！他们本来只是要让他们离开房间，
but the two of them, I don't know if you remember Jenna, kept yelling at each other as they left. It was so good. So good. Sometimes I think about what days would I go back? I would go back to the shoot. I would as well. I also think about characters days would I go back? I would go back to the shoot. I would as well.
但他们两个——我不知道你记不记得，珍娜——在离开时一直在互相大喊大叫。太棒了。太棒了。有时候我在想，如果能回到哪几天？我会回到拍摄的那几天。我也会。我还经常想，有哪些角色的日子我也想回去？我会回到拍摄的那几天。我也会。
I also think about characters I wish had come back and I would have loved to see more of Magic Mark. Like maybe he really pisses Dwight off because they're in the same Dungeons & Dragons group. I don't know. Yeah. The way Dwight said Scram Wizard, you kind of felt like they had history.
我还经常想，有哪些我希望回来的角色，我真的很想看到更多魔术师马克的戏份。比如他可能真的把德怀特气疯了，因为他们在同一个《龙与地下城》小组里。我不知道。是的。德怀特说“快滚开，巫师”时的语气，你会觉得他们之间很有历史。
You know, Nelly is really touched by this magician sabotage. She gives a very touching speech. She thinks everybody is a brilliant employee in their own way. Robert agrees. He says, great party. This party is maybe one of the most successful PPC parties. And they tried to make it the worst. What does that say about this group? How is this one of the best PPC parties? Well, usually when they throw a party for someone,
你知道，内莉真的被这个魔术师的破坏行动感动了。她发表了一场非常感人的演讲。她觉得每个人都是以自己方式出色的员工。罗伯特表示赞同。他说，好派对。这个派对可以说是PPC最成功的派对之一。而他们原本是想把它办成最烂的。这说明了这个群体什么？怎么这反倒成了最好的PPC派对之一？嗯，通常当他们为某人办派对时，
the person does not enjoy their birthday or their day. They usually are like, this is the worst party I've ever been to. Nelly loved her party. Okay, so by that, I guess it was a success. Also, I just wanna say I like a carrot cake and I would not be disappointed to eat a carrot cake at a party there. Do you know how much butter and cream cheese is in a carrot cake so much? So much. It can't help it be delicious.
那个人并不会享受他们的生日或那个日子。他们通常会说，这是我参加过最烂的派对。内莉很喜欢她的派对。好吧，这么说的话，我想它确实很成功。另外，我只想说我很喜欢胡萝卜蛋糕，如果在那里办派对能吃到胡萝卜蛋糕，我一点也不会失望。你知道胡萝卜蛋糕里有多少黄油和奶油奶酪吗？超级多。超级多。它不可能不好吃。
I love it. A red velvet cake that everybody always cuvets and loves. It's really a cousin to the carrot cake. Sort of similar. So maybe listen, get your penis mold, put some carrot cake in it. That's a great cake. It's a great party cake.
我太喜欢了。每个人都梦寐以求并喜爱的红丝绒蛋糕。它其实是胡萝卜蛋糕的表亲。有点类似。所以也许，听着，拿上你的丁丁模具，把胡萝卜蛋糕放进去。那绝对是个好蛋糕。这绝对是个派对好蛋糕。
It sure is. Well, this episode is gonna end with some Hank's ass. Pam and Jim are leaving for the day and Pam goes up to Hank and says, I thought I was very specific about you not letting up a magician. Hank said, I have my eyes open. Jim's like, actually, he made it up there. Pam's like, yeah, he came and went. And then Hank has this great pass of aggressive sass moment where
确实如此。好吧，这一集将以亨克的毒舌结束。帕姆和吉姆正要离开，帕姆走向亨克说，我记得我说得很清楚，不准让魔术师进来。亨克说，我一直睁大着眼睛呢。吉姆说，其实，他还是上去了。帕姆说，对啊，他来了又走了。然后亨克就有了这个伟大的被动攻击型毒舌时刻，
he's like, wait a minute. You said it was a magician, right? You don't think he could have used. It couldn't have been. And Pam's like, you know what, let's just go. Let's go. Mm-hmm. Hank's ass. Hank's ass. Well folks, that's welcome party. We want to give a big shout out to Steve Burgess and Steve Healey for all their extra tidbits in this one. And thank you guys for writing in. You had such great observations and comments and questions. It just really opens up the episodes, we love them.
他说，等一下。你刚才说那是个魔术师，对吧？你总不至于觉得他能用。不可能吧。帕姆说，你知道吗，我们走吧。我们走吧。嗯哼。亨克的毒舌。亨克的毒舌。好了各位，这就是欢迎派对。我们要向史蒂夫·伯吉斯和史蒂夫·希利在这集里提供的所有额外爆料表示诚挚的感谢。谢谢你们写信来。你们有那么棒的观察、评论和问题。这真的让这些剧集变得更加丰富，我们太爱它们了。
We will be back next week! See you then! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
我们下周见！到时见！拜拜！感谢收听办公室女士！《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，詹妮弗·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金西出品。我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。
Our theme song is Rover Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特创作的《罗弗树》。你本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。